can you explain why a movie does not
make business sense it's such an
interesting question and an interesting
model when you talk about
the the the movie industry and the film
industry and
it
it's
the reason it's interesting is because
hollywood's always existed in this
bubble because uh it was always so
difficult to be able to create
entertainment and technology wasn't
democratized so no not a lot of people
could make entertainment and so
it whenever entertainment was made
especially a film whenever a film was
made it was a very special rare thing
and a lot of that defied
the uh the rules of economics and in the
rest of the world now it seems that in a
commoditized market and there's so much
content that
when you look at just the business of
filmmaking it uh it doesn't make a lot
of sense to a lot of people and if you
out if you go out and talk to a lot of
investors and the investors a lot of
times will tell you most times they'll
tell you that the economics of the
industry just doesn't make sense for
them where
you you you put up you put a lot of
money in especially say like a
independent film uh independent film
venture you put a lot of money in up
front uh you you don't see any return
for a long time uh there's no sort of
incubation model that you see out of
silicon valley or or even just a a
startup business uh it it's it's a big
crazy roll of the dice you put a lot of
money in and you just hope and pray that
a bunch of people show up on the same
weekend and if they show up on the first
two weekends at least
maybe you get your money back but if you
if they don't then you lose it all uh
and it's it's just a high risk um it's a
high risk venture especially in a
commoditized market where there's this
hyper competition and so it's uh it you
know if you look at
even other aspects i mean you think
other aspects of the way normal business
is done typically the cost of the cost
of production will drive the retail cost
of a of a product for example and so if
if you can make a toyota for
ten thousand dollars then you can of
hard cost manufacturing you could sell
it for i don't know twenty two thousand
dollars and there you have a margin in
there uh to make your money but if it if
it costs ninety thousand dollars to make
a maserati
then then you have to sell it for two
hundred thousand dollars in order to
have your margin you can't sell it for
twenty thousand dollars or else you're
gonna lose money what uh and that just
makes sense right of course that's the
way that's the way the world works but
when uh in filmmaking i can make a five
thousand dollar paranormal activity and
you could make a three hundred million
dollar avengers movie and someone still
goes pays the same twelve dollars at the
movie theater for the product
and
that makes sense to us in the hollywood
bubble but for the rest of the world
that doesn't make a lot of sense and so
so now you're starting to see uh you're
starting to see a lot of conversation
around the variable pricing and maybe
blockbuster should be 50 movie tickets
and paranormal activity or indie films
should be two dollar tickets and maybe
we should scale ticket prices to the
cost of production uh trying to pull it
more in line with the way normal
business works and so uh it's
you know really
when it when it just comes down to it
especially if you don't have any
pre-awareness of the market the venture
to most people is just very very risky
when you especially when you add in the
uh the cost of pna and
you know how much you have to saturate
the market with with marketing just to
get people there it takes the break even
in a really crazy way i think steven
soderbergh said a couple years ago that
he predicted the the the death of the
independent film market within five to
ten years because the cost of pna was
going through the roof at this in this
tremendous uh in this and that's just
tremendous rate so he said
when he's when you know 15 years ago uh
you would spend three million dollars to
make a independent film and then you
would put an equal amount in to for pna
uh with the which the the distributor
would you put an equal amount in for for
the pna and then ultimately you work out
your breakeven from that right so uh uh
so usually if you put three million
dollars production three million dollars
pna what happens is you have to recoup
uh 50 you recruit 50 cents on the dollar
for the pna and so you actually have to
make six million dollars to to make back
the three million dollars of the p a uh
because you split it the the distributor
splits it with the exhibitors right so
uh so that's how it would work out but
now steven soderbergh says especially
with independent films everything's so
competitive and they're so oversaturated
and the market is so commoditized that
he says
you if you want to be a blip on the
radar
you have to spend at least 35 million
dollars of domestic pna 35 million
dollars of international pna
just so people know that you're out
there because there's so much stuff
hitting the market all the time
so uh so let's take a five million
dollar movie for example if you make a
movie for five million dollars and then
you spend
35 million dollars domestic pna 35
million dollars of international pna
that's 70 million dollars of pna which
means you have to make 140 million
dollars
to pay back
to recoup that right because you have to
split every dollar with the exhibitor
and you recruit 50 cents on the dollar
so you have to make 140 million dollars
plus the 5 million
production budget which means it's a 145
million break even on a 5 million movie
why does that matter this is why it
matters independent filmmakers require
uh and rely on going to investors and
saying will you give me your money so
that i can make my movie and so just
imagine the conversation of going to uh
an investor and saying i need you to
give me five million dollars of your
money so i can make my movie and all we
need to do
is make 145 million dollars at the box
office and you get all your money you
get all your money back
does that make sense at all
it really doesn't it doesn't to most
people now some people have a you know
they have an appetite for risk and and
and they you know and they want their
granddaughter to be able to star in in
in a movie and so they don't care to
fund it and and they do it for other
reasons vanity projects things like that
but more and more investors now today
it's like that just doesn't make sense
that's why studios love to do
a hundred million dollar movies this is
where we've seen the death of the 20
million dollar film i think is
is because think about like a hundred
million dollar movie put a hundred
million dollar production budget
with a hundred million dollars domestic
p a hundred million dollars of
international pna that's 200 million
dollars of p a you recoup that 50 cents
on the dollar which means you have to
make 400 million dollars back plus the
hundred dollar 100 million dollar
production budget that's a 500 million
dollar break even on 100 million dollar
movie
so how many 100 million dollar movies
make 500 million dollars
as opposed to a 20 million dollar movie
making 250 million dollars
right
now all of a sudden the 100 million
dollar movie makes maybe more economic
sense than the 20 million dollar movie
because the pna is thrown out all out of
whack right so uh so you know as
filmmakers we look at films through
through the lens of of the art and the
the films of the the through the lens of
the story and what we want to achieve
and what we want to say culturally but
we failed to put ourselves in the seat
of the of the investor and we and this
is something that i've learned i had to
i'm not a naturally inclined business
person uh you know some people are super
entrepreneurial and they get their mba
and things like that but i'm not a i'm
not a natural business person but the
more i was i i was talking with
investors the more they would and the
more they would tell me no the the uh i
would say why doesn't it make sense to
you
yeah and they would explain why this
doesn't make sense and the and when i
look at it from the
investors point of view then i'm like
wow yeah that is kind of crazy and
that's why we're seeing
independent film investment dry up more
and more because just the economics of
the business model
just doesn't compute with the people
that have to fund the whole thing
and so you have to understand that
they're coming from it usually by and
large investors independent film
investors aren't filmmakers they're
business people right they're and
they've made their money in other other
sectors right so they're looking at at
everything through a completely
different frame than the filmmaker by
and large and
i think the more filmmakers can get in
tune with the economics
surrounding
a film and figure out how to
reorient the economics of the venture to
match the economics of a of a consumer
brand venture or a regular like a
silicon valley startup figure out how do
we how do we start to
have the film venture
look like one of those other things
and uh i think if we do that then we're
going to see maybe an uptick in the in
the amount of investment that now goes
in to independent films which would be
great for everybody right but it's just
going to take a paradigm shift movies
aren't as special as they used to be
because there's so many of them and so
uh we can't just rely on
movies being as magical in the eyes of
investors before we can't dazzle them
with a movie i don't think as much now
we have to we have to make sense to them
and and we have to be empathetic to the
seat that they sit in
is the film industry the only industry
where to graph out what you talked about
and really go down line by line it
doesn't make business sense or are there
other industries where that's very
similar well i think when
when you look at
what you typically look for is the
difference between a commoditized
business and a non-commoditized business
and these are big ten dollar words but
you know the difference is uh you know
commoditization is where it is is a term
where you're in a market where where
you're no longer unique and uh because
there's so much competition there's
there's uh you know hyper uh competition
and over saturation that has flooded the
market
most businesses operate and commoditized
markets
but
businesses that operate outside of
commoditized markets by and large can
set their own rules and they can defy
those odds because what they're doing is
so special and so unique they kind of
get a pass
because they're you know they're
creating something that hardly anybody
else is creating
until other people start duplicating
that and they become commoditized as
well and there was a time when when the
smartphone was not commoditized and so
all of a sudden you know apple and steve
jobs they they could sort of set the
rules of the game of the economics of
the smartphone uh and it was up to them
not the market forces but
one now i think
smartphones have become commoditized in
such a way that you know that uh uh
that it's it's a different market than
it was you know 10 15 years ago or 12
years ago however long smartphones have
been out right so uh so so i think you
know when when you're looking for the
businesses that operate
outside of a normal paradigm you're
looking for the businesses that that
that are just super unique that uh that
don't have a lot of competition and when
you don't have a lot of competition
you're you know i'm from kentucky and
they and they call that being in the cat
bird seat if you're in an advantageous
situation um
and and entertainment used to be that
and filmmaking used to be that because
it was always too hard too expensive too
difficult uh to be able to make a movie
we we didn't have access to the camera
technology into the post production
technology we didn't have access you
know we had to shoot on film and film
super expensive we didn't have the
digital technology and we definitely
didn't have distribution i mean that the
the the the biggest shift i think for
for filmmakers you know in in you know
since the invention of the of the the
the talkie is uh the the internet being
a distribution uh uh mechanism and
because now the app the the the ability
to create and the ability to to
distribute has been democratized to the
filmmaker but always before
people didn't have the technology to
create and even if you figured out how
to create you didn't know what to do
with it because you couldn't distribute
and so that that that that
that was that was a that was tough and
so
the only people that could create
movies were you know five or six
companies in the entire world that had
the the technology and had the
infrastructure for distribution that
could do that so
anytime a movie would hit it would it
would be super special and it would it
would be an event and it would be
because we just didn't have a lot of
them coming out i mean think about think
about i remember when i was a kid uh e.t
was in the movie theater
for
over a year i believe all is around a
year right just in the theater the
theatrical run
now you know uh star wars was in there i
think 44 weeks uh the original star wars
movie you look at something like even
back to the future had like a 35 week
run in movie theaters
now you look at avengers in-game which
before the re-release avatar was
objectively the
the most successful film of all time
avengers in-game
that was in movie theaters what three
months
and then it was pushed out there's too
much stuff being being pushed into the
system right there's too much stuff in
the pipeline i mean there's there's
there's uh you talk to show runners they
say 15 years ago there were seven places
that you could sell a one-hour drama now
there's 75 places you can sell a
one-hour drama right everybody's
everybody's making stuff because the
technology's become democratized and so
so it's it's
we the entertainment industry has
shifted
from a non-commoditized very special
magical like dazzling
glittery thing
into
the same bucket as
smartphones and potato chips and coffee
shops and you know everything else that
that is commoditized which is now
forcing filmmakers and executives and
studios and and everybody that makes
this stuff now we have to re-learn and
uh uh what are the what are the rules of
the game what are the economics of the
game how do we how do we shift this to
better compete in in a commoditized
market it's uh
i think i'm completely convinced that
the shift into a commoditized market
is
i think for
for fans
it's the best thing that's ever happened
because we got as much content as we
could we have more content than we could
ever consume
with more movies we could ever watch
more tv shows that we could ever watch
more books we could ever read more games
we could ever play more songs we could
ever listen to we can't watch everything
on youtube we can't like there's more
tick tock videos than any one person
could ever consume ever which is great
for fans but the commoditized market i
think is the single biggest obstacle
facing filmmakers today the the the the
obstacle of access and creation has been
solved
right because we got cameras we have we
have we have you know if you've seen the
the the uh the uh the new iphone the
iphone 13 that that they announced like
the camera technology and that is
absolutely amazing right even iphone 12
absolutely amazing what you can do with
the camera technology with that right uh
but even then beyond just the phones i
mean you can go get a red camera a red
epic for you know for a few thousand
dollars uh you know and you can rent a
lens you know for for you know several
hundred dollars over the weekend and
you're able to do that you didn't used
to be able to do that now you can and so
uh so so that has been solved
access and creation has been solved i
think for for for uh filmmakers
distribution has been solved for
filmmakers we know now how to
get
our stuff to audiences we know how to
get it in front of people we know how to
build community we go direct to consumer
in about 35 different platforms right in
addition to the sort of the other
traditional platforms of you know
selling to the studios but even if you
want to go direct to consumer we have
the ability to do that the fact that i
can i can shoot a video right now and uh
uh hit a few buttons and upload it to
youtube and instantly it's in you know
six billion people's pockets is is it is
insane and crazy and awesome and
exciting so access has been solved
distribution has been solved
but now we've traded those problems in
for a new problem which is how do we
survive in a commoditized market how do
we out punch
three million other things that are all
competing against each other somebody
said
to me recently
they said making a movie today is is
like being a needle in a haystack
because you just release it and there's
so much other stuff i don't actually
think it's being a needle on a haystack
i think releasing a movie in today's
market is like being a needle in a
needle stack
if you're an if you if you're a needle
in a haystack at least you're unique
but now when you release your horror
movie into the market that's awesome
that's such an amazing achievement right
but
a thousand other people are releasing
their horror movie
at the same time
and you're no longer unique and now you
have all this crazy competition and now
you have to figure out how to out punch
your way
not
you know out punch your way from the
from the the glut of horror movies but
also all the other movies and all the
other television shows and all the other
books and then don't even get me started
about the tick tock videos in fortnight
and things like that that that pull
everybody's competition or it pulls
everybody's eyeballs right and which
could create this hyper competition
between all platforms right so it's it's
it's that
it's that obstacle of a commoditized
market that i think
needs to be the focus of filmmakers as
we go
out of 2021 into 2022 and beyond we need
to figure out
again how to obviously you need to make
a good movie and
and you need to tell a great story you
need to have rich characters all that
all the craft stuff still applies i'm
not talking about that but now we have
to shift the paradigm of our minds and
say what kind of model and business
model and ip model
can i
launch
that is not going to survive 1997
paramount pictures hollywood because
1997 was great but it was a long time
ago we don't live in that market anymore
today's market is a commoditized market
and i need my plan and my model and my
approach
to survive that
and that's a completely different
conversation
what is the business model for
filmmakers today it's a complicated
question because
the question could be
what should be the the business model
for filmmakers today or but but what is
the
the the model for filmmakers today i
think still sits
wholly
in that traditional model of you know i
got to go to the studio and i gotta you
know you know
option my option my script and go
through the development process and you
know and go through that whole thing
there's the whole traditional side of
the business that's still
moving along uh but now
on the outside of the studio system then
you're uh you're looking at a different
business model that is is more ip
focused and i think if you if you really
study the market and understand the way
the market works
it's about how do you launch and grow ip
and uh
and and this is this is not a new
concept because we've known for decades
that everything that we see on tv is
always based on a book and you know even
the the stuff that we know is the most
original we think is the most original
stuff we've ever we've ever uh uh you
know considered and we we love the
originality of this limited series or
this interesting film
98 of the time you trace it back and
it's based on a book
and the reason it's based on a book
isn't because hollywood's in love with
books it's because they love the
pre-awareness that the books bring they
love the community that's already built
for the book and it skews the risk
analysis into the favor of the filmmaker
when they say hey let's let's take this
book and let's make it a movie it's just
a lower risk investment and so uh so
so
ip creation and establishing ip in the
market is has has always been a thing
and but now in the with the
proliferation of other platforms and the
the the democratization of other
platforms where normal people can have
access to these other platforms such as
podcast and
webtoon and
what short stories on wattpad uh
comic books things like that
now the business model for creators is
how to take their ip and attack the
market
in
whatever platform they can so that they
could establish a market presence grow
the community
of that around that ip actually get fans
and then once they have fans then maybe
down the road they go and shop this
thing for for film and television uh
because when you do that you can
actually have a conversation uh because
you you have something established in
the market and you have fans and you've
established pre-awareness and i think
pre-awareness is is is vital in in
today's market because of the high-risk
economics of of filmmaking because the p
a budgets because the bud the the
production budgets are are just
increasing so much i mean you look at
you look at uh the lord of the rings
series on amazon they spent 250 million
dollars just for the rights and then
they spent 450 million dollars in
production for one season of tv and so
you're spending three quarters of a
billion dollars on a season of
television and so
they're not going to do that
with something that hasn't been
established in the market the only
reason they're comfortable with uh with
spending three quarters of a billion
dollars is because
lord of the rings is an established ip
in the market and that and there's a
legion of tolkien fans and and they've
tested the the previous the hobbit
movies and lord of the rings movies and
and it's been around for a zillion years
and all of a sudden it skews the risk
analysis into the favor of of the studio
they said i think we can do it i mean
you look at the foundation series that's
coming out on on apple that apple's
releasing and uh that that that was a
series of books that's been around
forever uh and and a lot of people maybe
won't know that and think oh this is
just original filmmaking now it's
established i.p in the market but
but used to europe
you know the only way you can do that is
through a book but now like i said you
can you can do that in a variety of
different ways and so one of the most
option things in hollywood right now are
podcasts podcasts are wildly popular as
far as being optioned and you look at uh
what amazon did with homecoming uh not
beyonce homecoming but the other
homecoming with julia roberts uh the uh
the the drama series and that was a
podcast you look at something like night
failed it was a podcast you look at what
hbo max
they they greenlit the calm app tv show
i don't know if anybody you're familiar
with the comm app the comm app's been a
top 10 app in the app store for the last
10 years the meditation app it's just a
meditation app for that promotes uh the
proposed mental health and keeps in
makes you calm and helps you meditate
and hbo max just green lit a tv show
based on the app
which
makes no sense
other than
there's a brand there and there's a
community there and there's
pre-awareness in the market they'll hire
a writer and they'll hire producers and
they'll hire talent that'll make it work
but what they were looking for is is
there the pre-awareness in the market
and you see something with angry birds
angry birds launched into the market not
as the animated films launched in the
market as a mobile game
and
so i think that is the new business
model for creators is how do i how do i
not wait for
netflix or amazon or universal pictures
or disney to to
give me permission
to make my dreams come true
i don't i don't want to wait for netflix
to give me permission to tell the story
that's in my heart
it it it it you'll be waiting forever
right and and and you'll be deceived by
the fact that there are some people that
netflix does come and make their dreams
come true and they give them the big
giant check but but for every one person
that's waiting for that that it actually
works for you know there's there's you
know a hundred thousand people hundred
thousand filmmakers that
that never get that break
and it's not because they're less
talented it's just because it's a it's a
hard industry and it's competitive and
there's a lot of super talented people
out there and it's tough to be able and
the line around netflix is you know 10
blocks long figuratively speaking uh
with people that want to get in netflix
right so so it's it you know
people are waiting for these studios
to give them permission to to follow
their heart and tell their story when i
say
that's
that's cool
but don't wait
or at least while you're waiting attack
the market
while you're waiting launch your ip in
the 10 or 15 or 20 ways that we have at
your fingertips at all time that you can
do for very little or zero money
like you know a podcast you can you can
take you can take your iphone and you
can download anchor an anchor is is a
free app on the app store that will
allow you to hold up the phone to your
ear and it records your podcast in just
into the phone and then it distr you can
put bumper music and you can edit it and
then it distributes it into the the
apple podcast store and it puts it on
spotify all completely for free
and then you can use the the
distribution platforms and social media
and things like that to to get it in
front of people start building your
audience and you can actually tell the
story that you want to tell while you're
waiting on netflix
but the trick is then
if you actually grow the community of
people
that
that love your podcast love your story
uh and and you know are engaging with
your brand
you've increased your chances from
hearing from netflix because you've
actually created pre-awareness the
market
right and you you accelerate i mean i
there was there was a there was an ip
that i had uh uh we we we sold we sold
to fox
it languished in development when the
turnaround we got it back and uh
we had played that game for seven years
trying to shop it finally got it shopped
when the turnaround got it back seven
years and i thought
what would have happened if i would we
would have been running a podcast the
entire time what would have been what
would have happened if i would have had
comic books in the market and release
self-published novels into the market uh
we wouldn't when it goes in the
turnaround we wouldn't be at zero again
we would have had fans and we would have
had a brand and we would have had ip the
film and television wouldn't have worked
the way we wanted it to work and then
we'd have to kind of reorganize that but
at least we would have done some other
things and attack the market in a way
and and not just wait for a giant studio
to give me a giant ed mcmahon check and
say i give you permission to tell the
story that you've always wanted to tell
and it's uh so so i'm very
very bullish
on
encouraging filmmakers
don't wait
launch
launch launch use all the stuff that we
have all the tools in the toolbox to
launch the ip
if you know if you know uh uh
people that can produce music work with
them to maybe tell a story through a
song and launch that uh if you know how
to write a short story launch you know
launch that if you know how to do a
podcast do it that way uh do a web tune
do you know do do something
and uh one
it it helps you
not
be frustrated as you wait to hear back
from an agent and sending out query
letters and the whole game that we all
know which is i'm not saying that's bad
i'm saying okay let's do that but while
we do that let's do some other things so
you're not just sitting around waiting
to hear back from people you're actually
doing something right which keeps you
it just keeps you happy as a storyteller
to be able to tell your stories i mean i
you know personally
i found myself
years ago
as a writer
the things the things that i wrote most
were pitch decks i found myself writing
more pitch decks than i were that i did
scripts and that was disconcerting to me
right because that's sort of what you
kind of fall into in hollywood is this
crazy game of just trying to like hustle
something and and and you're doing a lot
less creating and just a lot more
pitching right and so uh so you know
there's there's a i think there's an
artistic and a soulful benefit to
launching ip in the market just
satisfies you as you wait for the the
big guys to come and make your dreams
come true but then there's also a legal
benefit to it and so you know i consider
myself a recovering lawyer i started my
career as a lawyer uh uh and almost
completely recovered as a lawyer but
from a legal perspective if if you can
establish
an ip in the market
there's a lot
greater chance of you getting a better
deal on the back end if and when the
studio comes and wants to participate in
into a feature film if you just write a
spec script and you go and like like you
know like filmmakers do and like writers
do and you go sell that spec script and
it's not based on any pre-existing ip
that is it's just an original idea and
you sell you settle inspect say you get
on the blacklist and and they snatch it
off the blacklist and they they they
give you a deal that's awesome it's it's
it's
by and large a wholesale acquisition
it's we're taking the whole bucket of
rights
and we'll give you a check that's a high
five handoff that you know you you go
off and you know we'll take this and
we'll go and make this movie but they
have all the rights to every
platform ever created and here forever
two will be created until the end of
time there's all those big lawyerly
clauses in there they own everything
right they take the whole deal
theoretically they give you a check to
make you feel better about that right
which sometimes
that makes you feel better other times
it doesn't um
but if you say publish a book
self-publish a book and and uh and that
book sells and you're able to then get
that to be turned into a movie
the deal that is then done is a
different deal it's then you have uh
what's called a split rights deal where
they come and license the right to adapt
the book into movie
right so they take the film and
television rights
right but it's a license deal for the
film the television rights and you
maintain your other ip rights
video game comic books merchant you know
things like other things that you want
to create right and uh which is much
better in success of the movie right or
the tv show or whatever they do then all
these other rights become more valuable
and you've retained them
simply because you were able to
establish the iep in the market and you
didn't you didn't go to the studios
first right so so even if you don't want
to talk about the uh the the uh sort of
the creative benefits of attacking the
market and being aggressive with the ipa
and not waiting right and being passive
as as your fake lawyer as for that that
i would give you this this legal advice
never just sell a spectrum to a studio
it's crazy just publish it self-publish
it as a book first now ten years ago
before you could really self-publish
or there wasn't really podcast and there
weren't really these other things
then what what are you supposed to do
the only thing you could do is is just
sell it directly to a studio because not
not a lot of other other options right
now there are so many options it's uh it
makes it just doesn't make a lot of
sense to be able to go to them first
you're just you're just you're um
misappropriating and losing sight of the
broader opportunity of your ip so so i
think the new business model for
creators is a business model to attack
the market with ip attack the market
with ip and when you when you generate
the pre-awareness of the community it's
going to create residual benefits that
is that are not only going to make you
more attractive to the studios but it's
actually going to help you retain more
and control more of the ip moving
forward and from what i understand about
this new netflix series made yeah with
margaret quality
it started as an article a woman who was
in a homeless shelter with her child she
was cleaning houses and she kind of
wrote this thing about hey what people
don't know about what i know about you
from cleaning your house and that took
off and
then she did this book and then and now
and now we have this this show coming up
sure i'm looking forward to seeing it
and again that was someone that was
always wanted to be a writer had a lot
of tragic things happen and decided to
hunker down and sort of make the best of
it and look at now it's sure you know
that that's a rags to which the story
right there and and if she would have
just written that as a spec script
and then just started shopping that
around
i think we we would well we wouldn't be
having this conversation today because
because it would have gotten it would be
languishing in the crazy game that is
the spec
world of hollywood right she she was
able to take this and then launch it in
a different way let's write the article
let's let's do it let's launch it in a
different form let's then publish the
book let's let's do it as a blog let's
do something else right and and then we
we grow awareness we grow the
pre-awareness we we've we've actually
established the ip in the market and
then guess what especially when it
becomes popular then uh then then the
studios want to get involved and that
deal and i'm not privy to the the
specifics of the deal but but i would
guarantee that that deal that was made
for that particular uh that particular
ip
is a better deal than she would have got
if she would have written the spec
script and tried to sell that spectre at
first i don't think she would have sold
the spec grip to begin with
but in the event that she would have it
would have been a worse deal than what
she got now simply because she was able
to establish it in the market right but
see see this is the interesting thing
it's it's a paradigm shift with with
filmmakers typically filmmakers uh and
and screenwriters and listen i include
myself in this umbrella so it we we
we want to focus on filmmaking and
screenwriting and and and we feel like
if i just write my five pages a day
everything's going to work and i don't
want to learn how to do a podcast like
that's not me i don't want to learn how
to make a website i don't want to i
don't want to uh
you know write short stories
i'm a screenwriter right and
and
i wish i wish that person would have
been
born in 1978 and then you know was able
to
be able to operate in you know late 80s
90s hollywood because uh because it was
just as a different market you could
kind of you know specialize like that um
but uh but but it's just it's a
different market and and there's this
this uh there's this
hesitancy
for lack of a better word if if i say
that euphemistically there's this
hesitancy to broaden your scope of
creative to be able to launch
an ip in the market you feel like
you're you're doing something that's
less than screenwriting you're lowering
yourself to do a short story you're
lowering yourself to do a podcast
there's this this you know this this
artistic judgment and you feel like you
you and maybe you just judge yourself of
like man that this means that i'm if i
was good enough i'd be able to sell this
thing right and you judge yourself for
it and and you shouldn't judge yourself
for that you it's it's it there's too
much stuff out there and it's way too
competitive and uh
i think if if if creators and filmmakers
and screenwriters if they have the mind
of a of an entrepreneur who's who's
launching a consumer brand you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna approach this
whole thing differently because you talk
to any entrepreneur that that says i'm
gonna start a pizza shop
right uh and i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm
gonna open the pizza shop and and it's
gonna be great because i have this
family recipe of pizza i've been working
on uh like they are forced to learn
a hundred new skills in order to launch
that pizza shop right you never hear
somebody say uh i want to launch my
pizza shop with my family recipe
of pizza and i'm only going to focus on
making the pizza
i'm not going to learn how to do payroll
i'm not going to learn how to hire front
of house back house i'm not going to
learn how to order i'm not going to
learn about management i'm not going to
learn how to do the register i'm not
going to learn about anything else other
than pizza and that's it i'm just going
to focus on my pizza and as long as i
make good pizza everything will fall
into place
odds are that pizza shop will never open
right because of course
entrepreneurs know i want to do a pizza
shop i know how to make a good pizza
okay i still have to learn how to run
the register and i still have to learn
how to market the right way and i still
have to learn how to you know how how to
manage my staff and i still have to
learn how to order all the food from the
wholesalers and things like that you you
it
you're forced into
figuring out five or six new things that
you've never figured out before and
that's just part of being an
entrepreneur and every entrepreneur will
tell you that like you have to you're
forced to learn 100 new things
what are those 10 new things that we
need to learn as screenwriters and
filmmakers what are the 20 new things
that that that we can learn uh as
creators that can help us launch the ip
and and here's the good part here's the
here's the punch line that i think is
the greatest punch line of all time it's
all there
on the internet for free
youtube is the greatest educational uh
platform in the history of mankind if i
want to figure out how to change a
1987 volvo station wagons carburetor
there's probably a youtube video that's
going to walk me through it
we can
go to go to youtube go to google and say
how do i
how do i create a podcast
and there's 17 articles instantly or 17
videos that pop up you can go to
linkedin learning and and uh or or you
can go to you know
whatever like a resource that you want
to use
and you can take the 7 to 10 to 27 hours
to figure it out and not that you can
connect with people that know how to do
it i had a buddy who he won the nichols
fellowship as a screenwriter right which
is a big deal nicholas is is a very
competitive um uh screenwriting
competition he won the nichols
fellowship he he pitched a movie to
paramount pictures as a result of
winning the the the nichols fellowship
he pitched the script to paramount
paramount said uh it was too risky
because it wasn't established in the
marketplace and they said we want you to
go and create a comic book and launch it
as a comic book and if you sell 10 000
copies of that comic book
come back to us and we'll make your
movie
so
he walked out of that meeting
super bummed not just because they
didn't make the movie but they said make
a comic book and guess what he was a
screenwriter he didn't know how to make
a comic book right which if this was
that would have been a big bummer
but because it was
he was able to go home
open up the laptop google how do i make
a comic book and he started reading and
he started finding out where the artist
hung out online in the artist
communities and art station and
deviantart and things like that he he's
he's learned the production workflow the
cost of making a comic book how they
were distributed he just started
researching
and he connected with an artist uh in a
like estonia or some europe eastern
european country that that that
he uh they decided to collaborate on
something they they scraped and put uh
one issue of a comic book together took
him months they put an issue of one
issue of a comic together and they they
distributed it digitally on amazon
and uh
made enough money from it to make an
issue too
and then they made enough money on it to
make an issue three and then they made
enough money on it to make it issue four
and then after issue four guess what
happened they got picked up by a small
independent publisher that said we'll
pay for the publishing of it right so
they did issue five and then after issue
five they're putting it all together as
a trade paperback all five issues
together and now four years later he's
right on the verge of his 10 000 unit
cell right and he says houston guess
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go back to
paramount pictures and tell them to make
my movie because i have to hit the ten
thousand dollar or the ten thousand sale
mark right but guess what i'm not going
to stop selling the comic book
why because it's an extra source of
revenue for me
and
i have a community of fans that love
this stuff right so why would i stop and
so now he self-identifies as not just a
screenwriter but he's a screenwriter
slash comic book creator
right he's you know there's there's this
there's this uh this term called
polymath right people that are good at
multiple things and uh we typically
lawed people in entertainment that can
do more right beyonce can sing and she
can dance and j lo can act and sing and
dance and and we always say all these
people are amazing they're entrepreneurs
and actors and singers and creators and
you know and we love that about people
we need to start looking at ourselves as
that because we have the ability to do
that and because all the tools are in
front of us so i think
that's the model that we have to hit is
is being willing to have that mindset
shift of
i need to learn some more i need to
broaden my own skill set right and but
when i do it's going to open up a no new
world for me because i'm able to
establish my p my ip in the market
why don't we see new ideas in hollywood
i think it's because of risk i think
when
you look at the risk analysis of
feature films or or television
the
there's a hesitancy of
taking a chance on a new idea you have
to you have to
think about hollywood as
not in a vacuum where you
there's all these middle managers in
hollywood they're all executives right
and uh there's there's there's a hundred
people that that are all involved in
everything in the decision of what to
make and what not to make uh and and by
and large
people don't make those decisions based
on what is the what's going to propel
the industry forward creatively and
what's going to be you know what what
does the artistic integrity of the of
the industry need and like they're not
asking those questions they're asking
the questions of
what can i do not to get fired from my
job
and uh you know if it's a lot easier for
these executives to
to
say no to something
that could potentially be risky than to
say
yes to something that could be
potentially risky and it not work out
and all of a sudden they get the blame
uh because they took the risk i mean if
if i'm if i'm a studio executive and i
have two scripts in front of me and one
is this really hip interesting
progressive edgy you know uh uh script
that really pushes boundaries in a
really interesting way uh that's a lot
of creative uh uh
edgy interesting things and then i have
the reboot of the brady bunch as a
feature film you know uh starring vince
vaughn as greg brady which actually
sounds sounds kind of good but yeah but
if i have that in front of me and that's
like solidly mediocre right uh but um if
i have those two things in front of me
the most
artistically interesting choice then is
the new idea let's let's promote new
ideas let's not go back to well in the
brady bunch right um
but
99 times out of 100 what's going to
happen is going to be we're going to
make the brady bunch not because we
think the brady bunch is going to be
better or uh one it has pre-awareness in
the market
right so it has a community of people
that already know what the brady bunch
is even if you don't haven't seen an
episode of the brady bunch
odds are people have heard of brady
bunch and so there's this market
awareness that that shifts the risk and
they think it's a safer bet and because
it's the safer bet they think if i push
my chips in on the brady bunch and it
gets made
and it doesn't do as well as we think
i still be able to keep my job
because i made the safe decision but if
i go all in on on a completely original
idea
and that that is the more artistically
interesting idea and it doesn't work
guess what who's on the chopping block
me for making the bad call
right and listen it may not be my fault
maybe other people's fault you know
everybody's kind of shifting the blame
everybody wants to blame somebody in in
and
and especially on the executive level
you know it it's you could only lose 50
million dollars in somebody else's money
so many times before they don't give you
50 million dollars to lose anymore right
and so it's tough uh that decision to
green light or not the green light but
that's not made in a vacuum they they
sit there and say how do i
you know how do i keep my nice
six-figure salary with my premium health
insurance and how do i keep my kids in
private school and how do i keep my wife
not having to work and do the things
that she likes to do and how do i keep
my house and my gated community and how
do i keep you know the the two cars that
i have and uh like what are the
decisions
that can preserve that
and
i'm going to do those
because then if i do those long enough
eventually
my boss will retire and maybe i get it
promoted and then and that becomes that
game and listen i'm not even criticizing
those people for doing that maybe i do
that in the same if i'm in the same
situation i have kids i got a house i
got a wife i got dogs i got things right
so and i don't want to get fired we need
health insurance like there's all these
other pressures that come in uh but but
if you if you now if you now look at the
entire industry as an industry that is
motivated
not on artistic integrity but how do i
keep my job
that really clues you in of why we don't
see a lot of new stuff that's why we see
reboots that's and listen largely
reboots don't work we saw that with
female ghostbusters we saw that with the
new terminator movie we saw that you
know we've seen that every now and then
they work right hawaii 5-0 worked i
think uh uh the you know there's some
that that 21 jump street i think worked
uh actually the times you actually see
it work i think it's when you shift
platform if if it was originally a movie
then they turn it into a tv show or
originally a tv show and they turn it
into a film that usually works more than
film the film or
show to show typically just as an
anecdotal observation uh but it's uh uh
largely reboots don't
work that well in the industry just look
at the numbers
so
why do they do it it's because it's the
safer bet
but even though we know it's not a safe
bet it looks like the safer bet so when
people come to blame
somebody
i can say well no everybody knew the
brady bunch it's not my fault it's vince
vaughn's fault it's the director's fault
somebody else's fault but mine right so
then i get it stay in my gated community
i mean it's really interesting i mean
look at the the executives i was i was
talking to the uh
with uh the
president of he had a really interesting
comment he said you know executives they
they live in the gated communities
and then they
leave their gated communities and drive
through the gate into the lot
and then work and then they drive back
to their gated communities and never go
east of robertson right and they live in
this weird little bubble that breeds
a different mentality than you know
than the consumer or the audience or you
know when we're saying why don't we have
any more ideas
it's not our money on the line right
it's easy to say there should be new
ideas we shouldn't make so many
superhero movies
it's not our money
like it's easy it's easy to say that if
you're not if it's if it was your 50
million or 100 million dollars that
you're actually
putting on the line
maybe that conversation changes right
because now you're like maybe i don't
want to take the risk on the
progressively interesting edgy
psychological thriller that doesn't have
any pre-awareness in the market maybe it
will end up being one of the coolest
most artistic films that we've seen in
the last 10 years but we've all seen
movies like that not be financial
successes this is when this is how they
turn in the cult classics right and and
we see movies and we're like how did
that how did that not work why doesn't
everybody see this and there's there's a
hundred reasons why a thousand reasons
why great films aren't commercial
successes and not being a commercial
success doesn't
not make you a great film artistically
of course right uh but when it's your
money on the line
it's a different story right and so and
so you have to and if and when it's your
job on the line when you're spending
somebody else's when it's your job to
spend someone else's money which puts
your job on the line the calculation
changes right i think it's that's a you
know i i had i had a situation where i
pitched a i pitched a tv show to a
studio and uh they were looking for
content for their their digital
extension of their of their network and
they they told me what they were looking
for i pitched this idea the the the uh
to a producer had a had a pod deal uh
with the network and he said
this is perfect i love it this is
exactly what we're looking for and i'm
super excited because i think oh well
this this deal's done this is great and
he said
what what book is this based off of
and i said oh it's not based off a book
it's an original idea
and his whole body language changed he
like slumped down and says oh
yeah it needs to be based on a book
and i and i said
no it doesn't because you love it
and you think it's perfect
and it's exactly what you need so we're
good right
he said no needs to be based on a book
so
is it possible
that we could find a book that already
exists
that
is kind of like the idea we can option
that book and then say this idea is
based on that book
and i said that's this is the stupidest
conversation i've ever had with anybody
in my whole life you said it's perfect
you said it's exactly what you're
looking for you love it what's the
problem and he said houston i do love it
it is exactly what i'm looking for is
this exactly what we need but the fact
of the matter is i am not going to take
something to my boss that's not based on
a book because i don't want to put my
job on the line for you
that's exactly what he told me
and i said i appreciate your honesty i
really honestly did like appreciate like
that insight i got it
i expected this guy to go out on a on a
limb stick his neck out
for
an idea and an ip that that wasn't
established in the marketplace didn't
have any community built around it
didn't have any market presence it was
risky and i expected him to assume my
risk which puts his job on the line and
and he didn't what he didn't feel
comfortable with that because he wanted
to he didn't care about the art
i'm gonna say he didn't care about the
art
he didn't just care about the art i mean
of course he wanted to make a good show
right but there was other considerations
that were very practical
he wanted to keep his job
and we forget that we we forget that
that in the music industry the a r
executives you know there's a lot of
undiscovered talent that may be better
than other people but but all of a
sudden uh i'm gonna sign the tick tock
star that is much worse than this
undiscovered talent because the tick
tock star has 12 million people that
follow the tick tock talk star on tick
tock
therefore if the tick tock star washes
out
it's not my fault because i took the
safe bet rather than i go out and pluck
the undiscovered dude from iowa that
doesn't have any following he washes out
guess what it's on me because i took the
risk i didn't i i took a risk and i lost
and and so the calculation changes then
this is why this is why uh somebody like
like jake paul or logan paul they they
can go out and they can they can fight
uh uh these these these named boxers
they can go out and fight floyd
mayweather i mean did logan paul fight
floyd mayweather because he's the
the the best most deserving boxer in the
world no
he did it like he was able to do that
because it was a safe bet like he had
pre-awareness in the market and then
just made sense and so like it just you
know that's just the the the fact of the
matter of it right like it's just jake
paul
can go and write a script and sell that
script to a major studio faster than 99
of independent screenwriters in
hollywood right now that are
19 000 times more talented than jake
paul
no offense to jake paul he may be a
closet screenwriter i'm not sure i don't
think he is but but you get what i'm
saying is is
it's not because he's better it's
because he's safer
and and the executives know that the
executives know that and and they can
they don't think that jake paul will
write better stuff but they think if
they bet on jake paul
rather than you
if jake paul doesn't work they can keep
their job so we always as creators as
filmmakers we always have to understand
the business of the business and
understand the very human calculation
that is going on
in the executive level or the investment
level or the people that are behind the
desk
it's not these decisions aren't made in
a vacuum it's not just what's going to
make the best movie unfortunately that's
not the case anymore right maybe maybe
it was back in
1977 maybe it was a different mentality
that went into executives but today's
executives it's a high-stakes
high-pressure environment and and
there's there's real careers
on the line there's real families that
rely on real salaries
and and
we just think
we just think well as long as our
concept's right and as long as our
three-act structure works and as long as
our character development's right then
if if if if i if i am able to execute
the art the right way
then then they should make my idea and
uh just it's just and then you get
frustrated when they don't and then you
see crappy movies that are released that
are reboots and you're like oh where's
the original ideas
just a more complicated
very human calculation that's going on
that's different than the calculation
you think is going on
well and people are voting with their
dollars
someone's seeing it whether they're the
ones that are also leaving a gated
community to go into the gated you know
parking lot at the local cineplex
someone's buying these tickets
and so i i you know whether they whether
they just are checking their phone the
entire time or not and they're not
really they're just going to appease
their their kids or their friends
is to not to be known right now but but
so someone is seeing these things sure
that's the hard part and and the ones
that these art house films or the these
very unique edgy indie dramas whatever
um
unfortunately the
their
people aren't always voting with their
dollars to show that they love that
stuff sure and and listen and you're
right the market decides the market
decides what it likes and what it isn't
like and uh yeah and and
that's the way normal business works
that's the way the world works the
market decides what works and what
doesn't and we can't just sit back and
make value judgments and say well my my
movie was better than that well
if the market has decided that it's not
now artistically speaking you know
that's maybe a different consideration
this is this is the the difference
between the oscars
and
the
people's choice awards or the just look
at the box office like really i mean
they don't give out the oscars just
based the best picture could be what was
the highest
achieving box office picture of the year
they don't do that they look at they
look at the art and there's artistic
achievement that's the focus of the
oscars but really the the the
the re the regular
the regular audience member you know
again i'm from kentucky we i don't you
know i'm not from the coast and uh now
that i've been on the coast for 15 years
i realize just it's a different
mentality when you're in hollywood
you know people seen all the oscar
movies and they've seen all the all the
the streaming shows and all the deep
cuts and they can you know but you go
you go to middle america you go to
wyoming you go to kentucky go to ohio go
to georgia
it's it's it's there you know people
don't people don't know the directors
they don't know the dps and they don't
know you know all the the deep cut indie
films and they haven't seen you know
david lynch's third movie he made out of
film school and like they
like
but but when you live in the bubble of
hollywood maybe new york right you
convince yourself that everybody thinks
this way and and you start making
you start making stuff for people in the
bubble
right listen not saying that you just
have to make
you know so the quote-unquote studio
crap you know the quote-unquote big
commercial high concept film you have to
make superheroes all the time there
there are there is room for
art
but
but i think ultimately
you need to figure out how to marry art
and commerciality that's the there's an
intersection that can happen and when
that happens that's that's magic i i i i
it it never
never ceases to surprise me of how many
filmmakers fight for the right to be a
starving artist
and uh they they they find pride in it
and uh i just i
can never understand it i would much
rather than be well-fed artists
still be an artist
but figure out how to operate in a
commercial environment where the
audience will vote with their dollars i
feel like we have to find that
intersection you know something like a
quiet place was was i think in a good
example of that it was i thought it was
a very well made interesting artistic
very very different choice of of how to
do a monster movie and very almost risky
in a way
but it had commercial sensibility and it
worked and you look at something like
ted lasso i think you know ted lasso i i
feel like is is is a really interesting
commercial success that isn't
game of thrones right like it but at the
same time isn't the office or like i
feel like this it's an interesting it's
an interesting thing if you look at
what's going on in the emmys you know uh
the the people that are cleaning up the
enemies it was you know the crown and uh
the uh uh you know queen's gambit right
the queen gambit was a huge commercial
success
but at the same time i think was a a a
wild artistic success as well i feel
like it felt fit that intersection and i
feel like that's
what a lot of independent filmmakers
struggle with uh is finding that
intersection uh but uh because they they
they you know
they need to they need to think outside
the bubble um and listen ultimately you
got you got to make what's in your heart
and make what drives you and and
sustains you right and so uh um but it's
you know it becomes difficult when
you're making stuff that
that uh that the market doesn't bear
right and if you're and if you're happy
with that and you're fine with that
muscle top that's great but uh but
ultimately i feel like we need to figure
out that intersection and if you can
again it goes back to that pre-awareness
conversation if you can figure out how
to take that
interesting
super artistic
you know edgy
ip
if that people don't want to touch
because it's it's too risky
if you're able to establish that in the
market in three or four different ways
or even one way like you establish it as
a podcast and it pops to the podcast and
now a hundred thousand people subscribe
to that podcast guess what
it's the same edgy progressive artistic
character drama idea but now all of a
sudden the studios are going to now be
more apt to take a a take a gamble on
that original idea because you were able
to establish in the marketplace first
right so i think you know that approach
really
really benefits people that don't just
want to make superhero movies or marvel
movies or zombie movies or vampire
movies or whatever you know the big
genre flicks or whatever it is they want
to do some different
artistic interesting things
even more these people have to embrace
all the tools in the toolbox they have
to figure out how to establish in the
marketplace let's let's prove the
audience and once we can prove the
audience then all of a sudden these
people that were that were nervous about
taking taking a flyer on it are are
going to be a lot less nervous because
they see that you've proven yourself in
the marketplace i had an investor that
said that that told me every single
uh movie that is pitched to him uh he he
he has the filmmakers go
he said he'll he'll invest if he decides
to invest he will only invest 80 percent
and it's 80 finishing funds and he makes
the filmmakers go and raise 20 the first
of the budget on kickstarter
right and and it's it's one i think he's
tested the horsepower of the filmmaker
but really what he's looking for is you
need to prove that there's a market you
need to prove to me that there are
people that will actually get behind
this thing and if those people that
actually get behind this thing guess
what okay cool how come with the the
other eighty percent but you gotta you
gotta generate the market first right
and so uh so i think
if you are one of the filmmakers that
have the
edgier
non-commercial idea
then you have to figure out a way to get
that story and that ip to as many people
as you can
aggregate the data and the analytics of
the audience and then use that to soften
the risk analysis that was was was
probably well against you that was
working against you but now you can
shift that uh now to potentially
depending on the success to actually
working for you in a great way
and and two with with the queen's gambit
as as sort of edgy and artistic as it
was walter tevis had already proven
himself with the hustler sure and and
and then it's the man who fell from
earth
and i'm not sure how all that fared but
so there were there was a succession of
of
of successes
you could call it and so if it had just
been an obscure screenwriter who wrote
the exact same thing
would they have taken a chance on it as
amazing as it was well this is this is
what they tell you when you go when you
go shop shop a a script that's non
unbranded content right uh they'll say
um
they'll say you need to go package this
you need to find attachments to this
and you need to go find an actor that
will say i'll act in this or you need to
find a director that says i'll direct
this or producer that says i'll produce
this and if you get the attachments
involved now all of a sudden they may
take a chance on an original idea that's
unbranded that's not based on anything
else because
they're getting the pre-awareness from
the talent
rather than the ip
right so uh and so yeah if you can get
you know if if you can get uh uh julia
roberts to say hey i'm in or get michael
b jordan said i'll i'll i'll be in that
that'd be great or you know you get uh
you know uh
the rock to say i'll i'll i'll produce
it and star in it right if you can get
that
then the game changes for you
the problem with that the practical
problem with that is it's difficult to
get attachments it's hard you know talk
to any agents and and like you know the
agents will tell you they'll they'll say
you know uh that their clients have
scripts they're the the people they rep
they have a stack of script that's
taller than my seven-year-old that
they're waiting for them to read to
decide what to attach to and then that's
the ones that actually get to them
right
but it's how do you get to these people
right how do you how do you like for the
for the the mere mortal filmmaker
how do you get to michael b jordan how
do you get your script to michael b
jordan especially if you're unrep now if
you're if you have a manager or an agent
then then you expect your agent to
figure out how to connect with their
agent and make the submission and things
like that but especially if you're if if
you're unwrapped it's like it's it's in
your impossibility unless you you know
see him at a club and you know you get
in the conversation or or or you know
your your sister is friends with his
cousin and you know one of those weird
gotta know people to know people type of
thing right that hollywood just
works you know with with in a lot of
ways but it's hard to get those
attachments i had a a buddy who was a
professional house sitter for
celebrities when they go out of town
like he's licensed and bonded as a as a
as a house sitter uh which is you know
god bless america that that can even be
a thing uh but but so he goes out and
you know he uh um
uh uh these celebrities go to town he'll
stay at their house feed their dogs feed
their parent things like that and then
uh and then you know there's somebody
there in case they get robbed or you
know
they think they won't get robbed if
somebody's in the house so but he was
telling me that he was at uh he was he
was staying at um
at a at an actor's house
who
was an a-list actor in the 70s late 70s
um
now is older probably a c-list actor you
know at this point not you know doesn't
do a lot of stuff uh but used to be you
know everybody knows him his big name
right uh and he and he told me he said
he would receive courier packages of
scripts and he would open them up take
the script out open up a room and throw
it in and there was this huge pile of
scripts there that this guy was supposed
to be reading through in order to decide
what to attach to
what's going to be your next movie right
and and it's just like
so frustrating for writers and and
because we're writing this stuff and we
send it out and we just we we're we we
think okay the rock's gonna read this
and i'm just waiting for the rock to get
back to me and tom hanks is gonna maybe
be in my movie maybe not right but at
the same but now you know it's it's
150 scripts
before he'll get to your script and who
knows when that is it's a hard game to
get attachments right if you can get
attachments great but but
i like to now say
i'm gonna i'm gonna now approach
ip in a way that um
that i'm gonna presume i don't get any
bigger attachments i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna not try to get attachments of
course you attempt to get attachments
but i'm gonna presume i don't and so
that if i do it's gravy it's not the
entree i'm not betting on it right and
so i'm gonna try to attack the market
build the ip with pre-awareness as much
as i can
with the mindset that i'll never get
attachments so that i can skew the risk
analysis myself through the con the
aggregation of the of the audience and
then if jennifer lawrence decides to be
in the movie then even better it's gravy
right it's it's the icing on the cake
not the cake itself right but but that
shows you the pre-awareness has to come
from somewhere
it's either coming from the talent or
it's either coming from the ip but it
has to come from somewhere right unless
this is this is my eternal caveat to
that horror movies
horror movies are this really bizarre
exception somebody like jason blum can
can can
uh they can make a horror movie with
nobody you've ever heard of with a
director you've never heard of uh with a
story that's never been been established
in the marketplace and and you can still
make those movies and they can still
make money at the box office and horror
movies defy all those rules
for whatever reason uh
which is interesting the horror genre is
very specific about that if you come up
with a concept that's great and the
visual concept that goes along with it
and you know figure out like a wildly
creative way to kill people and things
like that then then you can you can
still
you can still get that stuff made so so
uh which is great for the horror
for the horror industry
everything but the outside of the
horror industry
operates on pre-awareness in a major way
i actually like that idea for a movie
that the house sitter and that the guy
goes in and starts reading these scripts
because he's bored he has all this time
he's supposed to stay there and then he
starts writing himself he doesn't take
anybody's ideas but he just starts he
says you know what i want to do a
screenplay and he gets made i love it
that would be that would be awesome yeah
you should write that okay
maybe i don't know
just establish it in the morning i'll
check with your friends
houston what are your thoughts on
hollywood reboots what are we doing
wrong what are we doing right
i think reboots
in general
yeah i'm not
i'm not a huge fan of them i i think you
know i
in in in large respect you know
people talk about you know they ruin my
childhood and things like that like we
we have nostalgia about you know the
things that we loved before uh but at
the same time
reboots
reintroduce
the story to a new generation that that
wouldn't necessarily go back and watch
an older film and we have to understand
that that reality of it if you know i um
you know i uh i loved ghostbusters uh
when i was a kid uh but i tried to show
ghostbusters to my little girl and it
just wasn't jiving with her like she you
know it's different filmmaking different
storytelling styles in different eras
right i mean even even with with star
wars uh you know the original star wars
she's she just thinks it's like a weird
old movie uh because the filmmaking's so
different now right and so she likes the
new star wars movies more than the old
star wars movies uh when i think you
know artistically the old star
wars movies were better uh but but
with reboots i think
you know
is there a generation of kids that will
actually go back and watch the old 21
jump street series
probably not
should they yeah of course they should
of course yeah but will they
probably not
and so that means there's going to be a
generation of kids that don't know
the the 21 jump street story and so
rebooting 21 jump street in a different
way reintroduces the ip to a new
generation so
in that regard i i'm i'm i i'm down with
it i like it uh i think though what's
better is let's figure out how to do
a soft reboot but still extend the story
i think that's the sweet spot and you
really look to see you know something
like what jj abrams did with star wars
with with the force awakens he
essentially rebooted star wars without
rebooting star wars he he technically
told the new story but if you look at
the way that movie
was structured and the story and the
characters it was basically a soft
reboot of star wars for people that
haven't seen star wars
and uh it basically retold a new hope
just in a very new and different way and
uh and but at the same time for legacy
fans it still extended the story for us
so technically it was new stories for
the new story for us didn't ruin our
childhood because they weren't you know
just wiping away the old and
reestablishing the new and that's what
fans don't like about reboots they're
saying the thing that we love before is
now no more we're erasing that from
canon and we're we're we're now creating
this new thing and we're going to start
here comic book fans
it's referred to as a renumbering when
they they'll say you know this there's
superman 731 issue 731 they'll say we're
gonna renumber we're gonna start over
number one which means we're gonna wipe
out the cannon of all the old stuff
that's always painful for fans to do
that but that's essentially what reboots
do they say the old hawaii 5.0 is
no longer now it's the new hawaii 5.0
and the fans the old old
get surly about that because they're
precious and there's nostalgia and
there's memories attached to it and
things like that even though you know
technically is the new stuff better
because there's better filmmaking
techniques and better technology
maybe probably you know that's that's
that's a subjective call right but
but i think the sweet spot is let's
figure out how to do soft reboot reboots
that ex that extend for legacy audience
but uh but create a new entry point in
for a new audience find that that
intersection if the uh you look at what
they're doing with the ghostbusters and
uh my little girl didn't like the old
the old ghostbusters um then uh you know
the female ghostbusters that uh you know
when that dropped that just didn't work
because ghostbusters fans
rejected it
because they're saying wait a minute
like those aren't my ghostbusters
i love dan aykroyd and i love you know i
i love my ghostbusters
where's egon and all that like that's
the kind of nerdy stuff that that fans
get into now you know there are there's
also the layer of you know the the
misogynistic these are women and we
didn't like that there's that whole sort
of political angle to it but i think a
large degree
legacy ghostbusters fans just just
didn't like their their ghostbusters
being deleted for new ghostbusters i
think if they were if it was all men it
probably wouldn't have worked either
right may have been
a different commentary around it listen
and
you know of course i'm not denying the
fact that there were people that were
just misogynistic jerks about the whole
thing of course there was that i don't
know if that was the bulk of it i think
it just wouldn't work
regardless because that movie is so
precious to so many people uh that but
now
it's a whole different conversation with
the new ghostbusters movies that's
coming out which effectively is a is a
reboot of ghostbusters for people who
have never seen ghostbusters but it
still extends ghostbusters for people
that have seen ghostbusters the legacy
audience right and so you you have to
try to find that sweet spot i think of
of how do we
extend and continue
rather than
stop delete and then restart right and
so
that's i think that's what we
that i think is a better way forward
than just the the the hard reboot
um and and maybe there's a there's a
different term uh for it but but i think
you know from a from a you can't
you have to you have to get a buy-in
from a legacy audience especially
something like iconic iconic like like
uh like ghostbusters right uh that has a
community a fan community around it
maybe there wasn't a fan community
around hawaii five-o or maybe maybe
there was maybe there was i'm not sure
but uh but
things that have actual fan community
around it
i think i really feel like you have to
you have to you have to continue rather
than just restart and you know delete
everything that's old they're they're uh
uh uh
facing this with the reboot of the
pirates of the caribbean franchise and
uh which is crazy they're already
talking about rebooting pirates of the
caribbean i feel like it was just out
five minutes ago but uh but there it's
going to be a hard reboot
which means they're just going to start
over and start telling different stories
with a new jack sparrow and and and and
that's
that's that for all the fans that love
johnny depp as jack sparrow and all
those old movies
then then that's going to be a hard
tough pill to swallow to say
all this stuff that i love doesn't count
anymore and because now it's this new
thing and there's going to be a division
in the fandom you can't divide fandom
like that and expect to be a success and
so uh so so yeah i'm not ideal ideolo
ideologically against
reboots of like all reboots are terrible
uh i think some are smart and some
reintroduce
fans to new stuff like what if they
would i ever want them to reboot the
princess bride
no
right
but do do kids today go back and watch
the princess bride will they ever maybe
i don't know like that's the that's
that's the calculation right but but i
think it would be better to do
the princess bride
now so many years later that extends the
original but still is a soft entry point
for new fans but still serves the legacy
audience how do we how do we find that
balance i'm not saying it's easy
jj abrams did it with force awakens did
it really well uh but uh and i think the
ghostbusters is doing that really well
uh but it's not easy it's a balancing
act but i feel like in today's
fandom-driven market you gotta find that
balance
do you still love star wars now the same
way you did when you first saw it in the
theater or wherever you were absolutely
i consider myself just a huge star wars
fan i i i i love star wars i um
am wildly
not objective about star wars uh and you
know it's interesting from a you know i
i i try to be objective about star wars
but i find myself um
loving it anyway and i you know i i go
back and and i look at star wars and i i
you know i read i recently read the
script of episode one a phantom menace
and
may have been the worst script i've ever
read
like just it's just it's just a really
bad script in my opinion it was just
terri it's terrible
i still love the movie i still love the
movie uh and it's interesting i think
you know you look at some artistic
decisions you know how you watch black
swan and then you see how the george
lucas turned natalie portman into a bad
actress like how did that even like you
and mcgregor liam neeson and natalie
portman how do you turn those people
into and samuel jackson how do you how
do you turn them into bad actors uh that
are wooden and stiff like that's that's
hard to do he he did that they like they
weren't that great think of the artistic
choice of the second death star in uh in
return of the jedi i was thinking about
that the other day uh you have the death
star in in the first movie and then you
get to the third movie and they and the
and then the central plot is around uh a
second death star that that in today's
market i think would be just like
laughed at and people would say it's
lazy riding and doesn't doesn't make a
lot of sense
but i love it i love i love the original
movies i love the prequel trilogy i love
the new movies that were a mess in a lot
of ways uh i feel like the rise of
skywalker was three movies shoved into
two hours and it was pacing issues and
all this stuff but i still love it and
that's i think the magic of star wars is
that
star wars doesn't have to be perfect it
it it taps into
this
youthful
uh
whimsy this this uh
this your imagination and and things
just take over and and and it it takes
you to this childlike place where
you don't have to be objectively
filmmakery when you watch star wars
right and and uh you know of course i
want the movies to be good and of course
you want the craft to be great um but
you know star wars is star wars and and
and i'm still a huge fan i'm a fan of
what they're doing you know on the
streaming stuff with the mandalorian and
everything else um but uh um you know
for me
star wars is is is is like an old box
and some like an old empty box and me as
a dad i have a seven year old and a and
a six month old and uh it's interesting
like i'll look at an
empty box as an old empty box
but a kid looks at that empty box and it
becomes a spaceship or it becomes a
carriage or becomes a tank or it becomes
a castle or becomes all of those in the
course of 25 minutes
right i think
star wars is like
that old empty box
to
to some
filmmakers and writers and
artists and critics they say
that's that's there's nothing special
about that that's not great i don't get
it it's just a box but for me when i
look at star wars i look at at it like
the seven-year-old looking at the empty
box you know no that's not a box that's
that's that's that's an airplane right
that's a spaceship and uh and and it
takes a different lens to to look
through it and so you know i am i am
unabashed of of uh
of my love for ep uh for for uh
uh the last jedi right which is the most
divisive star wars film ever ryan
johnson's uh uh you know episode nine um
i loved it i didn't love everything
about it
but i loved it
i loved uh i loved uh um uh the ryze
skywalker i loved it did i love
everything about it of course not
they'll have everything about about
return of the jedi of course not but i
still love the movie as a whole i think
we've that fandom has gotten to a point
of this
deconstructionism of of they people pick
on things and they say all right this
doesn't you know i mean think about
with game of thrones and you know game
of last season of game of thrones gave
us you know the battle battle of
winterfell gave us one of the most
dramatic interesting coolest episodes of
tv ever filmed ever in history and the
only thing people could talk about the
next day was the coffee cup they left in
the scene and because that's today's
thing like that's just the way the
internet is that's just the way twitter
is and and people like to deconstruct it
and say oh that's lazy or they dropped
they they they fumbled the landing or
whatever they didn't end it right uh jj
abrams didn't do this right he didn't
get this character right i don't like
how ryan johnson did luke skywalker in
this and they nitpick and nitpick and
yeah and you know
things you know things could be
different things aren't perfect and we
don't love everything but ultimately
you know i i'm i'm a fan and i i love it
because it's just you know it's it's
escapism and and um you know and i try
honestly as a professional
and i think all of us professionals
understand
how difficult it is to make anything
and how like it's a miracle that any
movie ever gets made ever uh and so i've
i've learned to even look at
quote-unquote bad films and still
appreciate them like wow they actually
made that even though it's terrible and
i wasn't they didn't necessarily enjoy
it they still made it and the fact that
the fact that you know that that
anything gets made i'm gonna appreciate
it and if i can't do better than that i
try not to criticize it uh and say
that's garbage or that's lazy or
whatever um
again i don't love everything about it
but ultimately i look i look at i look
at the star wars films and and just
with with immense respect
for
how they've been able
to keep that ip alive over 60 years or
50 years however long it's been how much
they've been able to scale the brand how
long they've been able to sustain the
fan community and create the culture
that they have
to continue to to push artistic
boundaries of what they're doing with
the mandalorian and the volumetric
capture stage that they they built and
and uh just you know
the storytelling in the mandalorian what
they're doing what they're doing now
with all the crossover stuff that that
one on disney plus is absolutely
incredible you have somebody like a
character like ahsoka tano i'm going to
get star wars nerdy for a second you
have you have a character like ahsoka
tano who is a character from the clone
wars animated series that they then pull
into a different animated series star
wars rebels that they then pull into a
live action series of the mandalorian uh
and cast a live action actress and now
gonna spin her off to her own live
action series on disney plus what
they're doing from a trans me in a trans
media sense is just really super
interesting and and how they revived the
star wars i mean say revive
the star
it's not like it was dead but like the
way they brought star wars back in front
of culture with baby yoda
and and now we know as grosgu but but
ever like everybody was talking about
baby yoda just the cultural sensation of
baby yoda it's just really smart
interesting
choices that they make and especially
now start they just they have something
now called star wars visions where they
it's it's uh it's um
animated short films that are all done
created in the manga style uh so like uh
japanese animation it's all done in with
manga creators uh telling manga stories
uh in the star wars universe that are
very much catered to uh to a completely
new market a younger market a more
eastern market where star wars hasn't
been able to really get a foothold as a
brand very much and and and and it works
and it's good and it's in it and it's
it's powerful storytelling and um so i
appreciate them
as a fan i appreciate them as a
filmmaker and i appreciate them as
somebody who understands how to build
and sustain ip like the way they do it
is just a master class on
on how to keep an engine like that
running and not just running but
thriving in the midst of
multiple multiple decades this really is
a tremendous thing and it all goes back
to how george lucas
created and built the whole thing it's
really like he he approached it in a
unique way and they've continued to keep
that going
do you think dividing the fandom is by
design
i don't think it's by design i think
it's i think it's
a
byproduct of today's
toxic fandom uh that is just a thing
that goes on now but i i think if you
were to criticize lucasfilm uh for
something it's
it's with the movies
they
they didn't listen to the fandom um not
saying that star wars movie the star
wars fans should decide what's in the
star wars movies um i'm i'm very much
certain that if star wars fans somehow
collectively decided what the next star
wars movie was going to be it would be
terrible
there is artistic integrity and autonomy
with the filmmakers but if you look at
somebody like kathleen kennedy kathleen
kennedy is she's an old school
filmmakers filmmaker she's an old school
filmmakers producer you know the way she
used to produce you know old you know
steven spielberg stuff uh and um
she's very much a filmmaker's producer
she likes to let the filmmakers
run and make great movies
and uh
and i think part of
the misstep of of the the latest trilogy
has been
in
her letting the filmmakers kind of run
with their own
visions and the lego blocks don't fit
together with the trilogy as well and
not really being in tune
with
the fandom and and and what the fandom
you know the directions and what the
expectations are and uh and been able to
set the expectations with with the
fandom and and not that you can please
everybody of course you can't but um but
uh
in some with something like star wars
you just can't approach it
in the way you would in the other movie
it's just a whole other organism that
you have to understand that the fans are
part of the process now and uh and
setting expectation
and avoiding cognitive dissonance is a
really important thing with uh with with
understanding how fandoms work so if i
if if um
if if i was if i were to go to
the south of france for a vacation
and and i get there and it's uh overcast
and rainy and cold and super expensive
and everybody's grouchy and not very
nice i would come back from that
vacation very upset and frustrated
wasn't a great vacation
but if i go to new york city
and it's overcast and cold and rainy and
really expensive and everybody's grouchy
guess what that's new york city like i'm
not like i'm not frustrated that a bit
that's the new york city experience the
difference is what's your expectation
and so if if i have the expectation it's
going to be warm and bright and sunny
and everybody's going to be sweet and
nice and it's the opposite of that
that's where frustration kicks in
because of cognitive dissonance and so
managing expectation of audiences and
and and letting them know
the direction that we're going and some
of the things we're trying to achieve
and and and letting them have a voice
and and and and making them part of the
conversation and and and helping shape
some sort of expectation in their mind
not saying plot points or things like
that are big reveals i'm sorry just
general direction that that the
franchise is heading uh that
conversation is super important to have
the fandoms today and that's something
that lucasfilm and kathleen kinley
didn't do when it came to the the the
sequel trilogy as they call it and and
you and you see now all of a sudden you
know when when uh you know i think
everybody was on board for force awakens
but then when ryan johnson did the last
jedi and luke skywalker didn't act like
people thought luke skywalker should act
and there were some choices that were
made that were surprising and didn't go
that and then then all of a sudden rises
skywalker went in some different
directions
that started to divide the fandom and uh
and some people loved it some people
hated it and we they all couldn't agree
and
but but
there wasn't enough community building i
think they just took the community for
granted i think they said as long as we
give them a star wars movie everything
will work out and it just you know it
didn't didn't work but
that being said
you know kathleen kennedy gave us the
mandalorian kathleen kennedy gave us
rogue one which i think is one of the
best star wars movies ever made uh uh
kathleen kennedy has is you know giving
us uh
she brought in john favreau for for the
mandalorian she's the the book of boba
fett she's overseeing all that like
kathleen kennedy i think has done more
good things than
the bad things it just so happens that i
think the misstep was on the biggest
stage with the new trilogy because star
wars really is built around trilogies
and uh that's the legacy of star wars
and so you have to nail those uh uh they
i think we could fumble some disney plus
series and the fans would gripe about it
but you can't fumble the the the the uh
um the trilogy and i'm not saying it's
complete fumble but it wasn't
it wasn't as good as it should have been
from a from a from a trilogy standpoint
there should have been uh she should
have made sure that there was
there was a creative vision and a
creative plan
that was that was in place before they
even started the first movie and they
were able to see that through so there
would be lego blocks that connected in
the best possible way
make sure the community was on board and
understood the direction they were going
to they were going in to avoid the
cognitive dissonance and that didn't
happen so that being said the movie is
still wildly successful but but
ultimately it created this division the
fan base
but the mandalorian kind of brought them
all back together and so even though you
may hate last jedi and i love last jedi
we can all high-five on baby yoda right
and uh and so that's been that's been i
think a really good thing for the fandom
is is the mandalorians kind of brought
it all back so
should star wars ever make another
trilogy oh absolutely i think they
should make 100 more trilogies as long
as the market it will bear it as long as
star wars fans want more star wars
movies absolutely if star wars fans
don't want more star wars movies then
the no right the market should decide
whether they should make more or whether
they shouldn't make more uh i i would
love i would love more right
and i think we're gonna i think we're
gonna we're gonna see more i think we're
gonna see stand-alone movies and i think
we're gonna see trilogies i think the
trilogies will be approached differently
uh moving forward but patty jenkins is
coming in you know she she did wonder
woman they're both the wonder woman
movies she's doing a rogue squadron film
which should be great uh kevin feige is
uh going to be producing uh a uh
a star wars film taekwontiti is uh
writing his own star wars movie ryan
johnson
from what i've read still has a star
wars a trilogy that they're going to
allow him to do which will probably be
super divisive and
but i think if you give him a trilogy
that's just his it works a lot better
right uh especially after this what
we're seeing like his success in knives
out and things like that since then i
think has has changed his star power a
little bit to where i think people trust
trust him a little bit more with it uh
than maybe they did before at least they
should because knives out is great and
knives out too should be great as well
i'm a big ryan johnson friend if you go
back to brick and things like that he's
just great um but but yeah absolutely
100 they should they should continue to
make trilogies they can they should
continue to make stand-alone they should
continue to do animation they should
should continue to do live-action series
games uh uh board games video games
novels uh what they're doing right now
in in the publishing space is super
super super impressive with what they
call the high republic um uh
the high republic part of the universe
which is thousands of years before the
prequel trilogy uh you go back to the
the days where the jedi were like the um
the the wild west sheriff's uh you know
in in sort of this this really rough
part of the galaxy and and uh they they
have coordinated with multiple authors
and multiple comic creators and multiple
novelists and and uh and and they all
have have worked out this tremendously
publishing plan where they're where
they're publishing adult novels y a
novels junior novels comic books that
all tie in together to create one big
publishing experience that then is going
to spin into a live-action show for
disney plus that's going to be
called the acolyte which is going to be
set in the high republic era which they
just also announced a new video game
that's going to be set in the the
knights of the old republic
supposedly set in in a similar time and
uh and probably then probably become the
new trilogy i think part of the the the
problem with the sequel trilogy
outside of the lego blocks not fitting
together because the plan wasn't
installed is you're dealing with legacy
characters that everybody cares about
luke skywalker and han solo and princess
leia and chewbacca and so all of a
sudden everybody has ideas of how those
characters should go and how and what we
should do with them you can't kill that
one but you should kill that one things
like that i think i think any new
trilogy
needs to
unhitch from those legacy characters and
establish new characters and uh new
stories in different parts of the galaxy
uh dealing with different things and so
you don't have all that legacy baggage
that's why i think the mandalorian
worked is because it was it was it
didn't have to deal with any of those
legacy characters and we all like okay
we don't have any expectations anymore
of of how luke skywalker's story should
end we can all just
enjoy this new ride together and so i
think
i i think that will probably be the way
of a new trilogy um
but but who knows i mean right i mean
who knows the way it'll go i mean if
star wars is sort of built around this
idea of uh of of pulling in you know the
crossover of different things and taking
minor characters from the background of
this one scene and a new hope and now
we're gonna make that a major character
in the mandalorian and and that's cool
for fandoms and there's this very
incestuous incestuous approach to star
wars which maybe is not the best word to
use but maybe is the right word since
luke and leia actually kiss and then you
find out their brother and sister which
is all again one of those weird things
that we just love star wars so we
overlook uh but uh but but it's very uh
very connected and the way they dine
with the way lucas always dynamically
connected all the stuff and the
lucasfilm with the with what they call
the story group which is the the team
that oversees the connection between all
the different
video games and movies and tv shows how
it all works together so if there will
always be connection and crossover but i
think
moving past those legacy characters is
gonna
is gonna create it
create a more forgiving
uh perspective on it on a new trilogy uh
that they didn't have with the sequel
trilogy even though they had different
protagonists the fact that luke
skywalker was in there and han solo was
in there and you know jj killed han solo
in force awakens and it just like
freaked so many people out even though i
thought it was a kind of a powerful
interesting moment uh uh in the movie
really just made a lot of people mad
because they love han solo and they
think they should never die
star wars fans are weird like that but
it but it's it's i think unhitching from
those characters is really going to be
be the way forward so uh i really look
forward to all the new content whether
whether it's it's it's
it's it's feature films or not what i do
think though is that they'll really
manage the windowing of the release of
the films it was getting to a point
where you know they were they were
releasing one a year
and uh that i think
was was difficult especially when you
put in the marvel movies in the mix uh
black panther and solo were released you
know just a few weeks apart and and you
know there there was some disney
cannibalization going on i think the way
forward for star wars movies is just
spacing them out more right especially
if you have the disney plus content and
the publishing content and the the game
content to kind of go between the movies
to help continue to feed the fan base
between those big releases
i think that's going to make them more
special and um because once you start
kind of pumping them out so much
they start to lose their shine a little
bit um and um
especially when it comes to you know the
interconnected stories it's just it's
just uh they become less special so
windowing i think will help
youtuber mr beast spends four million
dollars a month to make what three or
four youtube videos what do you think
about that
well i think if the market
watches it and it works for him i think
that's great i mean i think you know if
his if he gets a return on his
investment if we get if the roi makes
sense
mazel tov i think that's amazing uh and
i am presuming that you know if you look
at his numbers and the subscribers uh it
seems like the market is bearing out his
approach and um so so i think it's great
i mean you know again with with any with
any budget right i mean uh with with you
know game of thrones spending 10 million
dollars for one episode of tv for the
lord of the rings series spending you
know 20 million dollars for one episode
of television or him spending four
million dollars for youtube video
if if if that
if that creates a positive roi and
creates something that people enjoy and
the audience responds to i think it's
awesome i think it's awesome i don't
think it's it's a necessity for
everybody i think
the trap is to think
is well that means i have to spend four
million dollars on the up on an episode
or or on a youtube video or if i don't
spend uh four million dollars then i
can't do a good youtube series or i
think people get in their head about
that stuff and try to create rules and
things like that uh but his brand is
built around these super complicated
expensive
stunts and crazy things that he does and
uh and i think you know that's that
works for him and obviously he gets
results from that and so
you know i don't want to criticize that
i think it's great and it's working you
know but but at the same time i think
other people
may can do a very successful youtube
series for zero dollars uh i don't think
it sets a sets a bright line
rule for everybody to follow but for him
he's making it work for sure
have you studied mr beast at all have
you sort of done a deep dive with some
of his videos sure yeah i've i've i i
don't i don't i wouldn't say i'm a fan
i'm not one of his fans that that
subscribe to his channel and watch all
his stuff uh but definitely aware of all
the different things that he has done
and how he's grown his brand and
diversified his brand in a really
interesting way and the philanthropy
he's he's done he does a lot of really
cool uh philanthropic initiatives so uh
so definitely aware and appreciative of
of his approach for sure
what do you think other creators can
learn from his success i think what
creators can learn from the success of
mr beast is
use the platform that you have in front
of you use the platform that is there
and for free that you don't have to uh
you know wait for cbs to give you a tv
deal to be able to uh to start building
your audience and this is a refrain that
i always go back to is use the tools
that you have attack the market with
what you have and and if then if your
stuff is good enough uh then you're
gonna start building building that
audience out and so that's what i love
about mr beast is is is he just used
what was in front of him whether it's
youtube whether it's twitch whether it's
tick tock whatever it is use the tools
that you have also uh you look at volume
i think you know mr beast uh
you know he he produces a lot of content
uh and uh it's not just
one thing every now and then like it's
it's you know his big stunt prank things
uh uh you know are windowed but there's
a lot of content that comes through of
the variety of his channels because he
doesn't just have one channel he has
multiple channels right and so basically
he's his own network if you look at it
in the traditional sense and so volume
of content in a commoditized market is a
strategy that's super super important if
you only do one thing every now and then
in a commoditized market there's so much
new content that hits the market your
one thing just disappears because
there's too much stuff that that sort of
buries it right so you have to be able
to uh take a volume based strategy to be
able to compete in in a commoditized
market and that's what mr beast is doing
lots of content on the platforms that
are that are available to him that the
platforms that that that he's on and
what i like about him is is is
diversification is is he has different
channels and different types of things
he tries different formats it's not just
a one-trick pony it's he's willing to
try
new and different things on different
platforms in different styles and
different formats and genres and and and
really diversify the brand and if you
look at uh
if you listen if you read warren buffett
and or listen to warren buffett which i
don't know if mr b's listen to warren
buffett or not but
warren buffett says
he never
he never suggests that investors invest
into companies that that operate and
commoditize markets because it's just
too this is just too difficult for them
to compete unless they have the right
strategy of competing in the
commoditized market which he says is
creating a branded ecosystem based on
diversification diversification and
volume and synergy is your stuff tied
together are you creating lots of stuff
and are you diversifying the type of
stuff that you're creating and the
platforms that you're creating on and if
you look at what mr beast is doing he's
really doing a great job of the synergy
of volume and diversification and so i
think that's why he's able to to to
compete in the commodities market which
is that's the big takeaway that as a
filmmaker for me is that's what i
learned from from him he's not waiting
on anybody to give him permission to
create his stuff
and now that he's created it himself on
this platform guess what he owns the
brand nobody owns that else owns his
brand and if if cbs or abc or amazon or
netflix or whoever decides to come and
say hey we want to do a whole you know
mr beast movie or a mr beast cartoon or
a mr beast uh series
he's now in a leveraged position to
where he will decide uh uh
how
how that deal will play out
because he owns his own brand look what
happened with with joe rogan and spotify
uh you know like he did a 500 million
dollar deal with spotify
for his podcast
because he owned his podcast because he
launched his podcast before he got
getting involved with spotify and grew
his own audience and that's that's what
i love about mr beast is mr beast owns
this brand it's his he doesn't have any
any uh uh
you know of these of these studios or
networks uh divvying up the rights or or
or controlling him or dictating the
content like he's in the driver's seat
of his brand which as a as a creator i
i'm always going to uh root for and i'm
impressed by and um and so that i'm a
fan of that um and that's why i think
filmmakers can learn from him as well is
own your brand
use the tools that you have in front of
you diversify and and attack the market
with volume he's doing all those things
and and it's and it's working for him
it's playing out in the market
what do you think about mr b's
purchasing 100 acres of land
and uh building a 10 million dollar
studio it's 23. i think it's i think
it's amazing i mean i think if you look
at if you look at what tyler perry did
if you look at what robert rodriguez's
of what he did he's following in those
footsteps as a youtuber which is amazing
and it the more you could
disintermediate
other people that control your stuff and
control your content or control the way
you produce the content or or how you
produce the content when you produce the
content where you produce content the
more that you can just own
your own brand in every way that's
always going to be better right and and
you know it's an asset i mean it's it's
you know he's now
a real estate
magnet right like it's it's uh the fact
that i mean that gives that's that's
valuable that's financially valuable but
the fact that he's creating his own
studios
is it it just shows
nobody's going to tell him how to create
window create and why to create so if
you're using youtube studios there's
strings attached if you use
as well there should be because they're
it's youtube studios right if somebody's
coming to my studio or your studio of
course there's you know you're gonna
tell me how i should act i should tell
you how you should act and how you
there's always going to be strings
attached and which means ultimately you
don't really own your stuff yeah you
know i mean it's like it's like moving
into a neighborhood with a with with
with a really aggressive hoa right the
fact that you know if you can't let your
lawn grow more than six inches high else
you start getting fines do you really
own your lawn at that point uh i mean
there's like an interesting like for me
i don't like that i don't like people
telling me how like when i need to cut
my grass or i can't how quickly i need
to remove my trash cans from the curb
before i get the ticket i don't like
that right i feel like these are my
trash cans this is my lawn i should be
able to do with what i want right i feel
like that's the american way and that's
and so i love the fact that
an independent creator doesn't have to
go to some giant conglomerate
to be able to make the stuff and this is
a refrain that i always go back to yeah
is is how does the how does the
filmmaker
not wait for permission from a giant
multi-billion dollar international
conglomerate uh uh to to say you can
you can create the stuff that's in your
heart how do you just go ahead and do it
yourself and by creating his own
production facilities just like tyler
perry just like robert rodriguez just
like you know im not shyamalan just just
like any of these independent creators
that go and do their own thing he's
doing that and he's gonna he's gonna
have his destiny in his own hands
that doesn't preclude him from working
with any of these other people but it
just puts him in more of a leveraged
position because he just has more
ownership over everything literally has
more ownership over the whole thing
we think it's only a matter of time
before mr beast will make a movie and
it'll gross 100 million dollars plus
what do you think about that oh yeah i'm
certain of it i think uh
he will be able to continue to grow the
brand to the point where if there's
demand for a feature film or or for
something uh like that or even a tv
series of course i mean you look at
something another youtube break out
the hot ones which was an interview show
on youtube that was wildly popular and
it was a very basic concept where this
guy he interviews a famous person and
they eat hot wings as they as they as
they interview and the hot wings get
hotter as they go right super clever
concept right that just you know that
slowly built a very massive audience
that 100 million people subscribed to
the channel and eventually then he gets
his own
real uh reality show and own real uh on
actual tv he now has an interview show
and he gets called up to the major
leagues because that's usually the way
it goes uh but he estab but he owns the
brand he established it first so that
typically is is the the
the path that that that uh brands go in
now does that
does that necessarily mean that he'll
have to do it no i think you know he you
know i obviously
i don't think he would need to do it for
any financial benefit necessarily i
don't think at this point he's super
motivated by money because he's been
very financially successful which i
think is a good thing so i think mr
beast will look at look at the options
of i don't have to do it for money so
the reasons i'll do it is
it are the reasons that will help grow
the brand feed the fan base in the right
organic way that makes sense for the
brand uh where people i think where
where brands get off is is it off track
is when they
do it for a money grab
and it it's not coherent to the brand
and it doesn't feel like it's contextual
in in in in a in a way that
that adds value to the fan base it just
feels like a
sellout payday right and and sometimes
it can feel like that uh but i think
with mr beast taking ownership the brand
in the way that he's done and been able
to amass
the serious wealth that he's been able
to amass with the brand that the
motivation won't be money it'll be
something else and doesn't mean it's
going to be great this doesn't mean it's
going to work but i do think
he'll probably follow that path um you
look at something you know a board game
um
that was that was created called throw
throw burrito uh is uh and exploding
kittens and there was there's there's
something uh that that created these
indie board games on kickstarter and um
and they got to be super popular and um
now they're being turned into cartoons
and you know and and tv shows and movies
and things like that because that's the
way the entertainment industry works
right is eventually you get you get that
big break for the big platforms i think
mr beast
will
will do something non-traditional i
think maybe mr beast because he has a
community
may not go to paramount pictures to make
the mr beast movie or maybe even not
even netflix i think maybe mr beast does
something very non-traditional like like
launching a movie as an nft on the
blockchain
and
pulling the community
in participation of of uh of the movie
through the nft so they could actually
now participate as as equity partners
in the exploitation of the film and and
try something different because there's
no downside for him to try that uh and
there's no reason he has to go to
traditional hollywood i think you know
just the the fact that he's been so new
media with everything and so outside the
quote-unquote system of hollywood
i i i would guess that before he would
go to a universal
pictures or or or paramount pictures or
disney or something like that or
nickelodeon i think it would be
i think you would explore something
non-traditional like launching it on the
blockchain which i think would be great
because the thing that makes nfts work
is community having an established
community that can jump in and purchase
the nft purchase the tokens that then
monetizes
the uh
the product the movie or whatever it is
monetizes the whole project and then
gives them that profit participation and
a stake in the actual brand that where
nfts fail is a lack of community is is
they launched nft and there's nobody
nobody there to buy them because they
haven't built community first the nfts
that are really working are the ones
that have community first then launch
the nft uh and so
the fact that mr beast has amassed so
many subscribers amass this huge
community i would i would be shocked if
if if he didn't explore something like
an nft to be able to launch a series or
launch a movie and you're already seeing
craters kind of moving into that so it's
not completely like untested waters uh
but uh i would i would guess that there
would be some sort of
willingness to do something
non-traditional outside the system as a
way to create that movie or create that
tv show
sorry guys this entire theory doesn't
hold water at all the massive
breakthrough success of the mcu has done
almost nothing on all caps to increase
the sales of marble comics as a matter
of fact the books are struggling big
time conversely iron man was a lesser
known marvel hero when his movie dropped
and the guardians of the galaxy were
mostly obscure comic book d-listers both
suggesting that it wasn't comic readers
that made the movies succeed it was also
the quality of the marvel movies as
movies that made people care so yeah go
ahead and try to launch a comic and or
novel and or video game while you
simultaneously meet the herculean task
of shooting and promoting an indie movie
good luck there you will need it sure
yeah absolutely i think i think if you
pull that apart a little bit there's a
couple interesting things that that that
i would respond to uh because i i want
to have empathy for that comment and
the the comments interesting but i'll
take the middle comment there
first about
the herculean task of trying to do it
simultaneous of a movie that's crazy you
should never try to be doing it
simultaneous to the film i would never
advocate you trying to create a comic
book while you're trying to make a movie
that's crazy you should never do that
you should you you should be creating
the comic book well before you ever make
the movie for sure like
yeah you can't be you can't be
anybody that's ever made a movie knows
how
all-encompassing it is to make a movie
you can't do anything you can barely
feed yourself uh and pay your bills and
take your dogs on the walk while you're
trying to like you know at the same time
of making a movie like your whole life
stops just so you can do it there's no
way you're going to be able to be
managing you know the production of a
mobile game and the production of an
album and the and the production of a
comic book while you're making a movie
so so
i would 100 agree with the comment about
that don't do it let's just avoid that
altogether now that doesn't mean you
shouldn't make a comic book and a movie
let's just make him at different times
right so now before you ever make the
movie let's make the comic book to then
grow the audience in a way
that that establishes pre-awareness in
the market i mean think about this think
about think about you when you make a
movie that's not based on let's just say
you find the financing let's just say
hypothetically you find magical
financing your grandma leaves you a
hundred thousand dollars in her will so
that you can make your your movie so you
make a hundred thousand dollar feature
film which is awesome right you have the
financing to do it if it's unbranded
content
when you release the movie you're
releasing it to to no fans
by definition there aren't any fans
because this has never been released in
the market before it's unbranded content
you haven't you haven't pushed it out at
all
so there isn't anyone who loves it
yet and it could be great i'm not saying
it's not great no one knows about it yet
because the movie's not out yet right so
you're releasing it into the market with
no fans just hoping and praying that
everybody shows up on opening weekend so
we can consider this a success right
so now look at look at the other the the
other path is we know that that it's
it's uh that any movie one when you
start production it's gonna be two years
before that movie ever sees a lot of day
but even even if you go through the the
normal you know pre-production principle
photography post-production distribution
process but let's say even before you
get to that to to to the production
standpoint
leading up to it
right you go ahead and establish the
market say with a comic book or podcast
let's just say podcast right so you say
you launch the podcast ideally maybe
podcast and comic book right but let's
just stick with one let's say let's say
podcast if you have 10 000 people
who love your podcast
that is connected
narratively to the movie that you will
you will be releasing in the future
right so you you you open the brand up
to 10 000 people
who love the narrative universe the
story the characters the concept like
they're in it right and then and now
they're your fans they're in your brand
they're supportive because we love this
podcast it's awesome we're fans of this
whole thing
when you make your movie and you release
your movie guess what you're doing
you're gonna release the movie and
there's ten 000 fans that already love
it
they already love it
they may not love the movie yet but they
love the brand
and releasing a movie to 10 000 fans who
already love it is better than releasing
a movie to no fans
that
to no fans right like that like that
that that's the punch line is it's of
course like think about this if if i if
i if i release if i release a podcast
and i and i
create 10 000 fans
and then i release a novel
i release that novel
into a market that's warm it's a warm
market not a cold market now i've warmed
the market with ten thousand fans now
there's ten thousand fans that can buy
my book
and then let's say i get twenty bucks
per book do the math ten thousand times
twenty that equals out to a profit
potential as opposed to
not doing anything first and then just
releasing my novel into the market to
zero fans
does that does that
mean that there's no way for me to make
money of course not there's people that
do that make money in books all the time
but it's a harder road to release to no
fans
than it is to release to 10 000 fans
it's reductive thinking you almost have
to make yourself a little bit dumber to
use common sense for that to make sense
i feel like we're overthinking it like
of course it's better to have 10 000
fans already
loving your stuff when you release your
movie of course of course
right i mean it just it just it just it
just makes sense and so so whatever way
you can establish the community of fans
any community of fans that love your
brand and love your ip ahead of the
release of the movie
then
when you release that movie you're going
to increase your chances for success
does it guarantee success of course not
but you have a higher chance of success
than if you release that same movie into
a cold market
that's the punchline now then if you add
in the fact that
there's probably not you you've
minimized your chance of gaining
investment
from a private equity investor or studio
because it's unbranded content right
like like that that's a whole other
conversation that just to get the
financing you need to have that market
presence by and large that comes by way
of attachment or by by brand awareness
of the ip right but but so so there's
lots of reasons you need to do this but
i completely agree you shouldn't do at
the same time it'll make you go crazy
right that's that you know it'll make
your marriage fall apart and make you
grow a crazy beard and make you stressed
out like it's just it's bad news like
you shouldn't you should not try to
juggle all the like the filmmaking is so
crazy difficult we all know being on set
it's just too difficult to do all those
things at the same time right
spread them out
warm the market
then release the movie so that's the
middle comment the second thing i'll
address about the comment uh really is
the first part of the comment where the
the commenter said uh that the
the mcu didn't boost sales of marvel
comics and and and i would agree with
that as well i would i would absolutely
i'm agreeing with the commenter more
than i'm disagreeing with commenter uh
and because there's a narrative reason
for that is is when they when kevin
feige launched the mcu it was a
different canon
than the comics
and so you know canon is sort of the
official narrative that goes along with
a franchise or an ip and so what is the
official story
and there were i mean there was what 70
years or of of of marvel comic narrative
that had been going on forever and and
when they started the mcu they wanted to
start a new canon because that was way
too much complexity way too much baggage
uh way too much story to deal with
adequately it just confines the
filmmakers too much right because
because there's you know
the only way you can make this movie is
you if you go read 3000 comic books uh
that doesn't become an attractive uh
entry point for filmmaker to want to do
right so uh so it's just too much
baggage and so they they they said the
mcu will be a special canon it's going
to be a new canon that the comic books
will still be the thing will be a thing
and they'll still have their own canon
and they'll have their own stories that
will continue but we're going to set up
a new completely fresh consistent canon
that starts with the mcu that won't just
be the movies they actually have a line
of comic books that that is a special
mcu line of comic books that's tied in
with the mcu that goes along with the
mcu but those comic books aren't part of
the the the legacy marvel comic books
that that you know that uh that are out
there and so yeah of course when when
when when the iron man movies and the
avengers movies and all these movies
came out they didn't boost sales
of the comic books
because the comic books didn't extend
the story of the movies and so from a
transmedia perspective the incentive for
the audience to migrate to a different
platform is that the the story in the
different platform is going to give them
more insight and more narrative and more
payoff uh of
the thing that they love and so if they
were to learn more about this these
movies and the tv shows and things like
that by going through the comic books
maybe they would have
but because
all marvel fans knew that with new
marvel fans or even legacy fans that
there was a disconnected cannon there
was no incentive for them to go uh check
out the uh you know check out the comic
books and uh and and i don't think kevin
feige
at marvel necessarily intended for these
things to to to uh for the the comic
book sales to spike so
that's why they didn't spike they broke
the cannon and there was never a
business objective or a creative
objective of kevin feige who's over the
puppet master of the mcu and so uh so so
so of course
of course those didn't spike now does
that mean see this is we don't want to
we don't want to conflate that to say
well that means comic books connected
with with movies don't work and there's
no reason because they no it
they can make it work like if the canon
would be consistent
with uh with the film and television and
and they work together now all then all
of a sudden they begin to feed each
other you look at the the difference in
how marvel treated the legacy uh you
know the the legacy comics um uh in with
marvel and and compare that to how
lucasfilm deals with the comic books um
in star wars it's very different and so
all of a sudden you know you you watch
the sequel trilogy and you have kylo ren
who is who is uh the head of the knights
of wren and uh and uh
in the movies the knights of ren
aren't really explained like who they
are and how how he got roped in with
those with that crew seemed just like
you know it's a kid that kind of got
involved with some
bad friends that took him in a bad
direction they sort of allude to it so
you can still enjoy the movie without
all that backstory knowledge right but
they revealed who the knights of ren are
what happened to to ben solo after he
left luke skywalker's uh you know jedi
academy and kind of went off on his own
uh and and uh they they tell that
complete story
in comic books and so now the comic
books is is now extending
the film uh franchise the trilogy and
now there's synergy between the two
things and so now obviously we have film
fans who are migrating over to the comic
book does everybody migrate of course
not everybody migrates right but you get
your the the comic books do absolutely
benefit
from the migration of a certain
percentage of the film fans that want to
dig deeper and know more or there are
some people that haven't seen the movies
that are into the comic books so then
find the entry point in the comic books
and then find their way over to the
movies because they are now interested
in the knights of ren and that's part of
the movies and so it can flow both ways
right so so you absolutely see spikes in
sales when there's intentional narrative
synergy what i call additive
comprehension between the works right
but that's an intention that needs to be
made from a business perspective a
business model perspective and also a
narrative
intention that goes along with that you
got to tie these stories together in a
very intentional way to have that happen
if you don't intend it from a business
perspective and you don't intentionally
tie these stories together narratively
of course you'll never see a spike but
that doesn't that doesn't
lead you to a conclusion of you should
never have a comic book right like like
that that's it's a complete like it
depends on how you execute the comic
book and how you and how you execute it
in the context where it goes along with
the film it's the contextual information
that you kind of need to be able to make
that work right so uh so so absolutely
uh uh
the the
the commenter is right in the analysis
but i think the conclusion that's
inferred from that analysis is is
incorrect you just don't want to
conflate it and apply it to oh never you
need to do a comic book comic books are
dumb like you don't need to get to that
conclusion let's just do it in the right
way if you intend it if you intend to
spike that means you have to do it the
right way that's all that means they
didn't
star wars actually did this with with
what they called the extended universe
which they when when lucasfilm or when
lucasfilm was sold to disney uh they had
been writing novels and comic books and
and especially novels for 20 years uh
and there were only hundreds of novels
and video games and comic books all the
stuff that disney inherited by way of
the purchase not just the original film
trilogy of the prequel trilogy there
were there were hundreds and hundreds of
of of
licensed works that were created and it
was too much
for
lucas or for disney to
figure out so they decannonized
all that stuff
and said this isn't an official story
anymore from from at this point on we're
creating new canon we're disconnecting
from this other stuff right so so
so in the same way the new stuff that
they've released doesn't spike
the sales of all that extended universe
stuff that that that's older because
there's a narrative disconnect right and
it's not their business intention so of
course whenever you have that disconnect
it's not gonna it's not gonna
achieve that result and i don't think
they're disappointed in it because they
never intended to do that in the first
place and the last part of the comment
is like uh you know talked about luck
with any luck this would have of course
you listen nothing's ever guaranteed
everything like you know whether it's
luck or kismet or or you know fate or
destiny whatever it is like of course
there's always going to be an element of
of
right place right time uh uh what do you
call it luck we call it just whatever
you call it karma i don't know there's
there's something that that this x
factor that has to happen for things to
be to pop off to be successful
no if anybody ever tells you that
there's a guaranteed
way or a guaranteed model of success in
the film industry or the creative
industry or creative content
production that there's a guaranteed
methodology
of like the silver bullet do this every
time and it's going to pop and and be
amazing and be huge if anybody ever says
that you need to you need to you know
run the opposite direction because it's
not true
it all you can have the the best laid
plans you can have the best stories the
best ideas the best business model and
and sometimes it just doesn't work for
a thousand different reasons
and it's not because
your business model is bad and it's not
because
your idea was bad or you're like just
sometimes it doesn't work and it's weird
and and it's just like
and or sometimes culturally
something it happens in it and something
pops off in a just right place right
time the right idea and who knew that
baby yoda would blow up the way baby
yoda did like you know like it was that
luck was that right place right time
what like what was it i don't know and
so so yeah like
this anything that i say is is is not
silver bullet i think you know
anybody that writes a screenwriting book
of like this is the way to stretch your
screen but that's not a guaran if you
use the structure it's guaranteed that
your screenplay is going to sell or be
good
of course not of course you need some
element of quote-unquote luck
in addition to
best laid plans and
and and and you know and approaches that
increase your chances right that's all
i'm saying is if you if you use a
multi-platform approach to attack the
market in as many ways possible to use
all the tools and toolbox generate
audience uh have a market presence for
your ip uh be able to to to create an
ecosystem that feeds itself in a
commoditized market before you get to
the big st the big film and television
investment heavy things that are so
risky for people and they don't want to
lose their jobs because they don't want
to take the risk if you just do that
stuff it doesn't guarantee
you selling anything it doesn't
guarantee you succeeding in anything it
increases your chances
you know from from a from a sp with a
sports analogy
if if if
if you just take an unbranded piece of
content
and and you just release it into the
market and you try to sell the script
you try to you know uh you just you just
you just put it out there right
it's like
it's like with the football analogy it's
like being back on your own one yard
line throwing a hell mary all the way
down the field
right
that's hard
like it's rare that that works it's very
difficult
right and and uh does does every now and
then
does does it work for somebody of course
and that's the trap you see somebody on
the other you know a few feet down from
you say oh they completed their pass
that means i can complete my pass which
is true technically it's true but you
may spend 20 years trying to throw that
same hail mary down the field and never
and it just doesn't work and that's not
your fault and it's just not doesn't
mean you're a bad person or a bad
creative it just didn't work so what i
say is
let's run a few plays to move down the
field a little bit let's do the five
yard podcast let's do the 15 yard comic
book let's do the seven yard
uh board game right and let's get to the
point to where we're at the 50 yard line
and throw the hail mary because
everything in the film industry is going
to be a hail mary everything even the
studios with the stuff that they do is
going to be hail mary's nothing's
guaranteed right but every especially
for independent filmmakers everything
that we make is going to be a hail mary
so but i would rather throw the hell
mary from the 50 than my own one
that's all i'm saying it increases your
odds increases your chances but you do
have that have to have that little piece
of magic you have to have that little
piece of magic or luck or whatever you
call it in order for these things to
work and that's
that's the cool thing about the industry
right you just there's
it's not ones and zeros like the matrix
there's there's something else that that
that comes in
to
all the stuff that you make and and you
know and and uh you know it makes
something come alive and that's cool and
that's interesting and that's what makes
it exciting so so i agree
with almost every single thing in that
comment which is which is but
maybe i have a different perspective or
a different angle in it and sorry for
those of us who don't know football what
is the definition of that type of past
oh okay yeah
sorry i forget no that's okay
yeah so uh so hail mary is is uh uh just
you know it's usually your last resort
you're way far back on the other end of
the field and and you just like throw it
way up in the air and just hope that
somebody catches it right it's not
really a you know a well-designed
tactical play it's it's the hail mary
let's just hope and pray that something
happens and it works right like that's
that's uh that's the hail mary and it
usually only happens when teams are
getting ready to lose
and they're running out of time and
there's nothing else to do except throw
it really far down the field really high
in the air and just see what happens
what can filmmakers learn from the pixar
theory i think what filmmakers can learn
from the pixar theory is is that
just how fans think and and for people
that don't know the the pixar theory the
pixel theory is the unofficial
fan theory that all the pixar movies
exist in one narrative universe and
they're all connected in crazy ways uh
where pixar the official line from pixar
is that all these things are
disconnected right and they don't have
anything to do with each other uh but
fans they've constructed their own crazy
interconnected universe and so uh what
what filmmakers can learn from that is
that innately
fans love connection they love things to
cross over they love the the one story
that they love to connect with the other
story that they love they desire this
and if if they don't see a connection
they will figure out how there is a
connection and if you look at fan
theaters not just the picture theory but
just like any fan theories there are are
fun and interesting but it shows that
the the psychology and the mentality of
the modern fandom that they crave
connection you look at something like um
you know with uh the fact that uh if you
watch episode one of star wars um in the
galactic senate scene there's a there's
a pod of aliens that are all ets
which means wait a minute that's e-t is
is in the star wars universe uh which
and so now these things are connected in
a really interesting way which then if
you then go watch et that makes that
that uh that um explains why e.t reacts
to the kid in the yoda mask not because
he's an alien but the reason he reacts
to the yoda mask is because he's he
knows yoda
because he's from the star wars universe
which means if when et makes the bicycle
fly at the end of the movie he's not
using weird alien magic he's using the
force which means et's a jedi which is
awesome and fans will work all that
stuff out
and and which is ridiculous but it's fun
but it's ridiculous but what it shows so
we shouldn't discard that as filmmakers
say oh that's just a crazy fan theory no
no like look at
why the fans doing that and and figure
out like what's the mentality and what's
the psychology behind that they crave
connection you think about this think
about imminent shyamalan what you know
people haven't been excited about in the
night shyamalan in 15 years right
but then when he made when he made split
right which was a solid movie and it was
good but the best part of split was at
the end when they were revealed the
connection to unbreakable
and that's when people said oh my god
i'm not shyamalan he's back he imagined
is
his filmmaking didn't necessarily
improve
he started connecting
his stories and the fans got excited
about it so then you had unbreakable
then he connected it with split and then
they converged those things into into
glass
and and he created his own little
connected universe out of those three
films which fans loved and it really
revived his career that one decision to
connect those films revived his whole
career in a great way right kevin smith
you look back kevin smith who broke in
with with the glut of independent
filmmakers that broke into the 90s the
the thing that separated him from all
those other filmmakers is the fact that
he started connecting interconnecting
all his movies his clerks connected the
mall rats was collected connected
chasing amy which connected to jay and
silent bob and and uh you know they all
existed in in you know this little town
in jersey and they they they you know
they referred to the different
the the plot points of the different
movies in a really interesting way uh
but still in the way that they could
still stand alone but there was obvious
there was a connection
that separated him from all those other
filmmakers and and and was able to uh he
created a community
around his ip that other filmmakers
weren't able to do because they didn't
connect not and listen i think we could
probably i think kevin smith would agree
that he's not necessarily the best
filmmaker of all those filmmakers that
broke broke in in the 90s right uh but
he was able to build just such a rabidly
devout community because the fans were
excited about the connections between
the stories and so so for me the pixar
theory is all
about the fans and the way they think
it's not about i mean it's interesting
to think about of like well the witch
you know the witch and brave is actually
the little girl in monsters inc and
because when you when you see the
witch's cabin there's a there's a
there's an etching of mike wazowski and
sully in the wood carving of the of the
wall which which uh which then i think
the theory says uh uh after
after cele leaves boo at the end of
monsters inc
she spends the rest of her life
searching for him and uses the magic of
the doors to ultimately like get trapped
in uh you know ancient scotland but she
she understands how to use the magic of
the doors to then turn people into bears
and the reason she turns them into bears
is she's trying to recreate sully in her
own life will always without you know
with tragic results and it's like
however the story goes right or the fact
that i think that the pixar series
theory says that
you know um uh if you watch the end of
frozen uh uh rapunzel and the dude that
rapunzel um uh flynn that do the
rapunzel mary's
they're at elsa's coronation which means
they're connected which uh then the the
the theory said that elsa's parents died
in a in a ship sinking accident and um
but they actually didn't die the ship
sank they actually made it to a deserted
island restarted their lives had a son
on the island who was tarzan and then
the ship that sank was the ship that the
little mermaid explores at the beginning
of the little mermaid when she finds the
fork and all that stuff and they create
all this connection
and that's fun
right but that's not the big takeaway
the big takeaway is what are they doing
like think of that think about what
they're doing they're they're working
hard
to create connection
that's what they want they love it they
that excites them right connection
excite that this is why it's why people
this is the brilliance of the mcu this
is the burnings of what what what of
what's going on with the mandalorian
this is this is this is this is what
this is even in video games with things
like kingdom hearts and and and when can
when you throw you know uh uh you know a
crossover character into a mortal kombat
game we love crossover and connection
you look at chicago fire chicago med
chicago pd all the biggest like raiding
ratings events in tv are those crossover
events right as a kid i loved it when
scooby-doo crossed over with batman and
robin and the the globetrotters and
there was the connection like we the
fans always loved that stuff and it's
always played out
which
makes me wonder
why would
a filmmaker
ever make things without connections to
other things
if you do you're going against the
psychology of the audience because the
pixar theory
for first and foremost shows the mindset
of the modern fan
which means when you create something
and you're not connecting anything
you're you're
you're going against the expectation the
audience and and you know ultimately you
know that's uh uh i think if you if you
create things
understanding your audience and
understand how they think and what
motivates them and what they like uh if
if you read up on this philosophy called
phenomenology uh phenomenology the
philosophy of of the the highest the the
the most art the greatest artistic
achievement of the artist is not the art
itself it's the experience that you
create
between the audience and the art the
experience is the is the achievement
not the art
but the only way to get the experience
is to understand
what the audience wants and how to
create that experience with the art and
it's the combination that creates the
experience so so you have to understand
the psychology of the audience
if you want to create that magical
experience and and the pixar theory
gives us a very clear window
into
how the audience thinks
so is that why people love crime
podcasts or puzzles because we're
connecting we're trying to connect of
course i think it's just how we that's
how we operate this that's how we work
the how our brains work right and and so
we're always trying to connect pieces
and and and our brain
our brain does it for us sometimes
subconsciously just how we are we like
we like these interesting connections
and it plays out in entertainment uh
whether it's superhero stuff whether
it's what the walking dead has been
doing with crossing over all their shows
whether what you know what hannah
barbara did way back in the day whatever
nbc does like crossover events has been
a staple of modern entertainment for
decades so this isn't a new thing it's
always worked right it's working even
more now in a sort of a modern
multi-platform transmedia market uh but
but this isn't sort of a new development
it's always worked right so i think
understanding as a filmmaker
understanding the psychology of the
audience and creating content that
connects with other content it's gonna
it's gonna it's gonna again just
increase your chances for your
entertainment to really
to really succeed in today's market